NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
HEARING- I WANT TO START WITHA
FEW REMINDERS WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE AND
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING MASKS ARE
REQUIRED AT ALL TIMES HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL AND AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OUTSIDE
TESTIMONY CAN BE PROVIDED. IN
PERSON AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION LOCATED OUTSIDE THE
CAPITAL NEAR THE NORTH STEPS
AND BY PHONE. THE NUMBER FOR
PHONE TESTIMONY. IS UP EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT FOUR SIX.
NINE THREE FIVE TWO. THE
NUMBERS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND ALSO
APPEARS ON THE VIDEO FEED ONCE
THE PRIMARY SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY TO REDUCE DELAYS
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
COMBINED IN A SINGLE Q. PLEASE
NOTE THE HEARING WILL ADJOURN
BEFORE ONE PM. AS THE ROOM MUST
BE CLEARED BY ONE TESTIMONY
LIMITS MAY BE APPLIED IF
NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THE
AGENDA ON TIME. THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT I DIDN'T ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWELVE SIXTY ONE ITEM NINETEEN
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY AND ITEM
FIFTY. I'M SORRY ITEM NINETEEN
AND ITEM FIFTEEN AB. SEVENTY
EIGHT- WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- I GAVE
THIS OKAY- I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
I GAVE THE WRONG NUMBER FOR-
PUBLIC ACCESS FOR- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THE TOLL
FREE PUBLIC NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. SO WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND START THE KID
THE HEARING AS A SUB COMMITTEE-
SO WE WILL START WITH AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO.
THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE TIME. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX A MEASURE
THAT REDUCES DUPLICATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LITIGATION
THE DELAY THE CONSTRUCTION OF
DESPERATELY NEEDED NEW HOUSING
BY CREATING A MORE EXPEDITIOUS
AND COST EFFECTIVE PROCESS FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO COMPLY
WITH CALIFORNIA HOUSING LAWS I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING. THE COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS AS
OF JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND OF
ITS RESIDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN DAY.
AS REPORTED BY THE CONTINUUM'S
OF CARE TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
AS A STATE WE HAVE RELIED ON
ONE TIME SOLUTIONS TO THIS
CRISIS AND HAVE WITNESSED ARE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION ONLY
CONTINUE TO RISE. IN CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
UPDATE THE HOUSING ELEMENT OF
THE GENERAL PLAN EVERY EIGHT
YEARS A PROCESS THAT CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE CURRENTLY
UNDERGOING. DUE TO THE CHANGES
OF STATE LAW GOVERNING THE
CRITERIA USED TO DETERMINE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS. IT IS
EXPECTED THAT MORE
JURISDICTIONS WILL NEED TO
ACCOMMODATE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER HOUSING TARGETS THAN
PREVIOUS CYCLES. IN MY DISTRICT
LAWCENTER THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WILL NEED TO
ACCOMMODATE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
HOUSING UNITS. UNFORTUNATELY
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO FACILITATING THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING IS A LONG
IN THE TOOTH AND LITIGIOUS.
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS
REQUIRED TO CREATE NEW HOUSING.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
SEE WHAT CLEARANCE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATE
AND SUBSEQUENT REZONING
ORDINANCE HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
CAUSE SIGNIFICANT DELAYS. AND
REQUIRE EXPENSIVE STUDIES WITH
ADDITIONAL COSTS AND
UNCERTAINTY SHOULD THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE BE
LITIGATED. IN THE STUDY OF ALL
HOUSING UNITS CHALLENGED IN
SEQUEL LAWSUITS FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS REGIONS BETWEEN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN. IT WAS DETERMINED THAT
THE TWO YEAR PERIOD WITHIN THAT
TWO YEAR PERIOD APPROXIMATELY
FOURTEEN THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS
WERE CHALLENGING SEQUEL
LAWSUITS AND I WANT TO SHARE
SOME OF THE STATISTICS. 98% OF
THESE UNITS WERE WITHIN
EXISTING COMMUNITIES MEANING
THEY WERE NOT IN NEW GREENFIELD
DEVELOPMENTS. 70% WERE WITHIN A
HALF MILE OF PUBLIC TRANSIT
STOPS OR QUARTERS PRIORITY
GROWTH AREAS IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S MAN
MANDATORY. HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS 78% OF
THOSE WARREN WHITER WEALTHIER
GEOGRAPHIC'S A GEOGRAPHIES.
SUCH AS THE WEST SIDE AS
OPPOSED TO COMMUNITIES WOULD
RELATIVELY HIGHER MINORITY OR
POVERTY RATES. AND LOWER
EDUCATIONAL HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THIS DIRECTLY INHIBITS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF STATE HOUSING
POLICIES AND IMPEDES THE
ABILITY TO FACILITATE HOUSING
PRODUCTION TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT CRISIS. PARTICULARLY.
IN COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT THE
MOST. AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
WOULD PROVIDE REGULATORY
CLARITY TO MUNICIPALITIES AND
ALLOW A MORE DISTINCTIVE PATH
TO COMPLYING WITH STATE AND
REGIONAL HOUSING CAPACITY
GOALS. BY LIMITING SPEAKER
REVIEW OF HOUSING ELEMENT
UPDATES TO A GENERAL PLAN
ADDITIONALLY AND THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT. WHEN IMPLEMENTING A
HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATE THAT
INCLUDE THE STATE REQUIRED
REZONING PROGRAM A MUNICIPALITY
WILL BE ALLOWED TO UTILIZE A
PREVIOUSLY CERTIFIED.
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS AND
LIMIT ANALYSIS TO SITE SPECIFIC
IMPACTS AGAIN. I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT WE ARE ALL WORKING TO.
REDUCE OUR HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION AND ENSURE THAT
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT'S ON
HOUSE STAR ON HOUSE NEIGHBORS.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE HOUSE
THEN WE CAN ONLY DO HAT IF WE
ACTUALLY BUILD THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES AND TOOLS TO ENSURE
THAT WERE ABLE TO BUILD. IN OUR
CITIES AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY IS
LOWER ACROSS SICK WITH THE
OFFICE OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI. THANK YOU OF SO
WE ARE READY FOR THE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. OF MODERATOR CAN YOU-
PUT HER THROUGH. YES ONE MOMENT
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO IS GO AHEAD. HOWEVER.
THANK YOU TERRY BYE LARA AND
MEMBERS OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CLARK PROJECT PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT MANAGER IN THE
OFFICE ERIC ARE STUDYING THEIR
BLOCKS AND SALAS WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSOR EIGHTY FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX INTRIGUED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARILLO
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY LOS ANGELES AND
CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE MIDST OF
UPDATING THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT
AS PART OF THE SIX REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT OR
REUNIFY. AND BAG REGION
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS HAVE HOUSING
ELEMENT YOU IN OCTOBER OF THIS
YEAR AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NOTED THIS PROCESS WILL REQUIRE
THE CITY TO ACCOMMODATE MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL HOUSING
UNITS WHICH ARE PERSPECTIVE IS
EQUAL TO NEARLY ONE THIRD. OF
THE CITY'S EXISTING HOW. OTHER
OVERALL GREEN AT HER FIFTY
SEVEN PER ARE LOW MODERATE HOW.
AND ALL OF THESE UNITS ARE NEWS
TO HELP RESPOND ON GOING
SHOPPING AT HOME. RIGHT LOS
ANGELES IS EMBRACE PROCESS AND
TO LEAVE THE FOUNDATION
REQUIRED TO BUILD THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDED TO
MAKE SURE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
CAN BE A REALITY FOR ALL
INJURIES. EIGHTY FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX IS A CRITICAL PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT WILL BETTER
ENABLE US TO ACCOMPLISH THESE
GOALS. IT WILL REDUCE THE
NEAREST OF UNNECESSARY DELAY IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR LITIGATION
ABUSE UNDER SPEAK WHAT THAT
WILL ONLY CONTINUE TO SET US
BACK AND EXACERBATE. THIS BILL
WOULD CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF
REQUIRED ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MUST
UNDERTAKE THE UPDATE OF THE
HOUSING ELEMENT. AND OUR
SUBSEQUENT REZONING PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO CREATE A MORE
PREDICTABLE PROCESS FOR
COMPLYING WITH STATE HOUSING
LAW AND ACHIEVING OUR HOUSING
AND SUSTAINABILITY GOALS.
ELDERTON NOT CHANGE ANY
REGULATIONS RELATED TO THE
CARIBBEAN FOR INDIVIDUAL
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT. NOR DOES
THE BILL EXEMPTS ORDINANCES TO
RESEMBLE TYPES FROM SECORD
RUBIO. STATE BUDGET AND MADE
THEM CHANGES THE RING A PROP
AND YOU KNOW THAT. RESULTING IN
MUCH HIGHER HOUSING TARGETS
HOWEVER OUR EFFORTS TO UPDATE
OUR LOCAL POLICIES AND
NECESSARY REGULATORY CHANGES
WILL BE LARGELY INEFFECTIVE FOR
THE COMING SEVERAL YEARS AT
BURDEN BY THESE UNNECESSARY
DELAYS AND LITIGATION. HOUSING
ELEMENT THERE BEING UPDATED
RIGHT NOW ACROSS THE STATE AND
IT IS VITAL THAT WE NEED A
CRISIS WITH URGENCY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. THANK YOU- I SEE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- SO WE WILL. OPEN
THE LINES OF MODERATOR PLEASE
APPLY FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION AND I JUST WANT
TO REMIND WITNESSES TO JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION.
AND YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THEIR FIRST LINE OF THE
LINE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE DAILY
CATHOLIC WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. X. WOULD
ALIGN NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
ARGUE CAPS- CHEERING MEMBERS
ARGUE BELGIUM WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL WE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WAY FOR
NEXT FALL. THE SERVER GONNA GO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS OF
INTERMARRIAGE. WITH THE
NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL AND
IBEW LOCAL THREE FORTY. IN
OPPOSITION AND LEFT FROM AND IF
WE STAND IN SUPPORT. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
TRADES. AND NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DESTRUCTION SHADES
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT IN.
NEXT ON THE LINE NUMBER FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MODERATOR ON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
CHEROKEE HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR- TO
FIX OUR CONCERN BUT WE ARE
RIGHT RIGHT NOW OPPOSE
MASTERMINDED. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALL LINE NUMBER SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
CHRIS CRITICAL OF LOCAL UNION
SIX SIX NINE ROAD SPRINKLER
FITTERS WE OPPOSE THE AMOUNT
FROM AND IT THANK YOU. WHAT
NEXT WHAT A LINE NUMBER FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA
ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND
CURRENT CAMP. IT'S AN ACTUAL
LINE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES BARTON RODRIGUEZ
I WORKERS LOCAL BOARD THIRTY
THREE IN OPPOSITION- LET THE
MANDATE THANK YOU. THEN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU DO A WHICH WHICH
MAKES THEM PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NUMBER
NUMBER THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU RON MILLER
WITH THE LA ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDED. AT THIS TIME I
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. THANK
YOU- NEXT I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT
UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. MISTER MISTER SIRE
TO- ATFIRST I WANT TO COMMEND
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- FROM A CITIES
PERSPECTIVE- THE RENOWNED ISSUE
IS A HUGE ISSUE- IT'S VERY HARD
FOR CITIES TO DEAL WITH STATE
MANDATES AND THEN RUN INTO
THESE ROADBLOCKS THAT KEEP THEM
FROM BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THE STATE MANDATE.
AND SO- WE'RE ARENA IS
CONCERNED A LOT OF COMMUNITIES
ARE TRYING TO DO THE PLANNING
NECESSARY- BUT BECAUSE OF THE
ROAD BLOCKS THAT ARE ADDRESSED
IN THIS BILL- THEY CANNOT. AND
FROM THE DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY-
MAYBE OUTSIDE OF LABOR- THEY'RE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THEIR
INABILITY TO PUT TOGETHER A
PROJECT AND GET IT DONE WITHIN.
YOU KNOW A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME BECAUSE THEY ARE CARING
COSTS AND ALL THESE OTHER COSTS.
IF WE ARE AND IF WE ARE TRULY
GOING TO TRY TO ADDRESS. AND
IMPLEMENT PROPER THESE ISSUES
THAT ARE GOING TO INCREASE OUR
HOUSING- I THINK. YOUR BILL IS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
SO- YOU KNOW EIGHT IT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE. THE PROCESS IT DOES
NOT ELIMINATE BECAUSE NOBODY
WANTS. YOU KNOW AND- S.
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY LESS- OUR
PROCESS THEY THEY WANT THEIR
ENVIRONMENT TO BE PROTECTED
CLOSE BUT WHAT YOUR BILL IS
TALKING ABOUT IS THE DUPLICATE
OF PARTS OF THIS AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A SECRET PROCESS DOWN ON
ONE SIDE AND THEN THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO DO
IT AGAIN AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER LAYER AND THEN ANOTHER
LAYER AND ALL THESE LAYERS
TOGETHER- AND I'VE SEEN PROJECT
AFTER PROJECT STALLED OUT NOT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A GOOD PROJECT
IT'S BECAUSE THEY USE THAT
THAT. THAT LAWSUIT FOR
LEVERAGE- TO GET SOMETHING THAT
THEY WANT AND I SUSPECT THERE'S
A LOT OF OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR
OPPOSITION IS. BUT BUT OUR JOB
IS TO REMOVE THE HURDLES THAT
ARE STANDING BETWEEN US IN
ACHIEVING THE GOAL. OF GETTING
PEOPLE INTO REASONABLE
REASONABLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING I
DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL EVER REACH
THAT- BUT TO IN ERE IN
CALIFORNIA- AND I THINK- I THIS
IS THIS IS A- A GOOD EFFORT IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND I'M
I'M GONNA MAKE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THIS. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A FARM. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND-
BUT I. I'D LIKE TO STE STE- PAS
AND HAVE OUR SECRETARY TAKE
ROLE. NUMBER THREE THAT'S I'M
HERE FOR YOUR SUPPORT MAYOR
CATTLE. FRIEDMAN YOUR REMEMBER
YEAH. YEAH YOUR I HAVE A
FEELING PARTY. I THINK SHE
CLEAR HERE THEY ARE POPULAR SO
WORRY. NUMBER FOUR. OKAY THANK
YOU- THIS CAREER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU- MATTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS- THIS IS A WE ARE
LIVING THROUGH A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME AS WE CONTINUE TO SEE OUR
OUR HOMELESSNESS POPULATION
CONTINUE TO RISE AND OUR- OUR
NEED TO ACTUALLY BUILD BUILD
MORE HOUSING AB. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX REDUCES THE PUT OF
THEM ARE REVIEW AND UPPER FOR
THE THAT THE LADY COMES. OF
DESPERATELY NEW BACK MORE
EXPERT AND OF PROCESS FOR LOW
JURORS. TO COMPLY WITH CAL
HOUSE LAWS I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING OUR
LABOR PARTNERS AND THOSE THAT
CALLED IN A WHO WE'VE HEARD
FROM AND WE WILL CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION SAYS THIS BILL IS
DOUBLE REFERRED AND CONTINUES
TO GO THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS FOR US TO GET TO. A
GOOD PLACE I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR THAT IN MY OWN PARTICULAR
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE ARE AT
WE ARE A LABOR CITY AND I WOULD
NOT BE INTRODUCING LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD NOT INCLUDE- THE
SUPPORT FROM THE BUILDING
TRADES AND OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS THAT ACTUALLY CREATE
THE HOUSING THAT'S NECESSARY
FOR SO MANY OF OUR OWN HOUSE
NEIGHBORS AND I HOPE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO GET TO A GOOD
PLACE. WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
ADDRESSING THE VERY REAL
REALITY THAT WE NEED TO REFORM
CERTAIN PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT SIMPLY JUST GET IN THE WAY
OF US BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY
COMPLY WITH THE PROMISES THAT
WE MAKE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
ACTUALLY FINDING SOLUTIONS TO
OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND
THAT INCLUDES OUR ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD. MORE HOUSING TO
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT IN AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU- SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY OUR
TOTAL OF SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO HOUSING. AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT SECRETARY KING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MAYBE
FORTY. YEAH EXACTLY OKAY. EVERY
THREE I YOU ARE FOR YOUR JONES
THREE HI REALLY APOLOGIZE YEAH.
YEAH YEAH PARTY I THINK HE'S
YEAH HI FOR FOUR HOURS. GOOD
GARCIA. WE HAVE FIVE ZERO WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN THANK YOU. I'M
NEXT WE HAVE AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU CHAIR AB AT ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN TAKES A MULTI
FACETED APPROACH TO SET
CALIFORNIA ON THE COURSE TO
MEET THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION TARGETS BY
MAKING CHANGES AT THE STATE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEVELS TO
PROVIDE TOOLS ACCOUNTABILITY
AND INCENTIVES FOR METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS TO MEET
THEIR TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
REGIONAL GHG EMISSION TARGETS.
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE THE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES CLIMATE
AND PROTECTION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT BY A NOW MAYOR
STEINBERG WAS A FIRST OF ITS
KIND LAW TO RECOGNIZE THE
CRITICAL ROLE OF INTEGRATED
TRANSPORTATION LAND USE AND
HOUSING DECISIONS TO MAKE TO
MEET STATE CLIMATE GOALS. SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRES
EACH OF CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN
REGIONAL METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS TO INCLUDE A NEW
ELEMENT AND THEIR LONG RANGE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANS A
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGY.
THIS STRATEGY IDENTIFIES WAYS
THAT MUNICIPALITIES CAN REDUCE
GHG EMISSIONS FROM DRIVING
WHICH CAN OF COURSE OF COURSE
LEAD TO HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES
AND MORE EQUITABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER REPORTS FROM THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD THE L. A. O.
AND OTHERS HAVE STATED THAT
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON TRACK TO
REALIZE THE GHG REDUCTIONS IT
EXPECTS UNDER SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE OR THE IMPORTANT CO
BENEFITS. AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN
REQUIRES EACH MPO TO CREATE A
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE TARGET
ACTION PLAN. AND DEVELOP. AND
THIS IS IMPORTANT A NEW BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO THESE NPOS TO
ACHIEVE THEIR TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE GOALS. THIS BILL WILL ALSO
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MAKE A GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO
TAKE ACTIONS THAT SUPPORT THEIR
NPOS. ABOVE HIS PLANS AND
REQUIRES THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
INNOVATIVE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. THAT
MAY SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
REDUCING THAT THOSE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED VMT GENERATES
MANY BENEFITS INCLUDING
ALLEVIATING TRAFFIC CONGESTION
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION REDUCING
GHG EMISSIONS REDUCING OUR
DEPENDENCE ON FOREIGN OIL.
IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH THROUGH
INCREASED EXERCISE. AND SAFETY
AND ENHANCING INTERACTIONS
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES. AS THIS
BILL MOVES TO THE PROCESS I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AND WE'VE
BEEN TALKING TO THE CITY'S
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO THE
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT AS IT
MOVES FORWARD. A TODAY I HAVE
CARTER RUBIN FROM OF THE
NATIONAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND WILL BEAR IT FROM
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND I
WOULD REQUEST YOUR I. BOATS SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT POLICY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- I JUST WANNA REMIND
THE TWO WITNESSES THAT YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE. OF ALLOW THE
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY. YOUR
LINES ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
MEMBERS THI IS CARTER WRITTEN
WITH ENERGY SEAT I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS TO HALT CLIMATE CHANGE
EXTEND TO OUR LARGEST SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GASES. THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
CALIFORNIANS ARE ALREADY
SUFFERING FROM THE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
POOR AIR QUALITY AND DESPITE
INCREASINGLY FREQUENT OF
PRESIDENT DISASTERS WE CONTINUE
TO INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT POURS MORE FUEL ON THAT
FIRE. OUR OWN STATE AGENCIES
HAVE RATED THE ALARM THAT OUR
CURRENT TRANSPORTATION POLICIES
ARE PUSHING MORE ROAD TO MY TO
ROADS BETWEEN- GENERATE OR
DRIVING. SO AB ALONE SEVEN
BUILT ON THE FOUNDATIONAL WORK
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND SB
ONE FIFTY. RECOGNIZE THE
FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE MEANS
GIVING CALIFORNIA SOMETHING
THEY CONSISTENTLY ASK FOR. THE
OPTION TO GET AROUND WITHOUT
GETTING IN THEIR CARS. AB ON
FORTY SEVEN FACILITATES THE
SHIFT BY ALIGNING OUR STATE
TRANSPORTATION BUTTON WITH
THESE PRIORITIES. WILL MAKE
SURE REGIONAL PLANS ARE HELPING
REDUCE DRIVING AND APPROVAL
TURN IT IS AT THE SAME TIME
THAT WE MAKE OUR VEHICLE FLEET
CLEANER. THIS IS IMPORTANT
THIRTY TWO CARBON EMISSIONS
FAST ENOUGH TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND AS THE CO BENEFIT. OF
REDUCING LOCAL AIR POLLUTION.
THIS BILL CREATES A PROCESS TO
GET REGION'S BACK ON TRACK IN
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS
EITHER CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS.
AND IT'S BILLS SUPPORT MAJOR
INVESTMENTS REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
HUGE APPETITE FOR THIS. THE
LAST ROUND ENACTED
TRANSPORTATION GRANT SOUGHT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
REQUEST TEN TIMES THE AMOUNT
THERE THE CDC HAD TO ALLOCATE.
THREE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN THREE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO VOTE
HI THANK YOU. HELLO AGAIN THAT
WILL AT THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IS THE LEADING SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIA CONCORD ERIN CLIMATE
POLLUTION. REALLY WITHOUT A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
HEALTHIER MORE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR THAT
SERVES ALL RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA
WILL SIMPLY NOT MEET OUR HEALTH
PROTECTIVE CLEANER CLIMATE
STANDARDS. LAND YOU CAN
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING IS
CENTRAL TO THE DISCUSSION WELL
WE'RE NOT ON TRACK TO ACHIEVING
THE CLIMATE HEALTHEQUITY
CONSERVATION AND SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS THAT WERE CENTRAL TO AT
THE THREE SEVENTY FIVE. SO
WE'VE YOU AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN
AS AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE ON SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE. I THINK YOU'RE THE
BENEFIT THE HEALTHCARE
COMMUNITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THIS IS SPECIALLY THE CASE FOR
OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE WHO ARE OFTEN
DEALING WITH CHRONIC HEALTH
BURDEN. DUE TO THE LACK OF
HEALTHY TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HIGH LEVEL
OF CURRENT PATIENT POLLUTION.
AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN WITH%
SUPPORT- GETTING CALIFORNIA
BACK ON TRACK AND BRINGING
LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE
AGENCIES TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY
BARRIERS TO ACHIEVING THE
REGIONAL CLIMATE GOAL. AND TO
ADD- AN MPA MPO TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE TARGET ACTION PLAN THAT
WOULD IDENTIFY KEY BARRIER.
AREAS OF INVESTMENT THAT EITHER
SUPPORT OR DETRACTING FROM
ACHIEVEMENT OF THE GREENHOUSE
GAS TARGETS- OUTRAGE TO AND IN
AND VERY IMPORTANTLY REPORT THE
INPUT FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES INTO THAT PLAN. AND
THEN CORRECTIVE ACTIONS THAT
THE NPOS TO TAKE IMMEDIATE ON
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE REGIONAL
GREENHOUSE. CRITICAL COMPONENT-
IN ADDITION THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE NPOS TO SUBMIT DATA
TO THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD THAT WOULD REALLY. SPELL
OUT HOW TRANSPORTATION FUNDS
HAVE BEEN SPENT. IN IN SUPPORT
OF THE DISABLED COMMUNITY
STRATEGY AND THE IMPACT OF
THOSE CHANGES. ARE THOSE
EXPENDITURES. ON CHANGES IN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED THAT ARE
CENTRAL TO THE AGAIN THE
DISCUSSION OF HOW WE GET TO A
MORE SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION-
FINALLY THE BILL PROVIDES- FOR
THE BLOCK GRANT FUNDING THAT
WAS DESCRIBED. AND THAT CAN
HELP TO SUPPORT ACTION NEEDED
TO BE TAKEN TO ACHIEVE THE
TARGET AND- SECURE THOSE LOCAL
HEALTH BENEFIT THAT WE KNOW ARE
POSSIBLE THROUGH MORE
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION. OFF
THE BOARD THE STATE REALLY
MONTH ENSURE THAT FUNDS ARE
SPENT IN LINE WITH THE
CHEATING. HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES
RATHER THAN SETTING UP FURTHER
OF COURSE. AS THE WITNESS FROM
NRDC NOTED- SO FINALLY JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE- ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD AND REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO. CONTINUE
CONVERSATION ON THAT NOW WE ARE
DRIVE OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU-
WE HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS THAT IN
BETWEEN. FROM BILL HEY. I DO
NOT THE BILL HIGGINS ON THE
PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME BUT IF
HE IS ON YOU CAN START ZERO AND
I CAN OPEN HIS LINE. STARTED.
ZERO I DO NOT SEE HIM OKAY OF
THE- OKAY LET'S GO AHEAD AND-
TAKE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF
OR OPPOSITION I'M JUST THEIR
NAME WITNESSES SHOULD JUST
STATE THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. WE WILL BE A
LINE OF SIXTY NINE. GIVE ME
SIXTY NINE DROPPED ONE MOMENT.
BORDERLINE OF FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER THANKS. THANK YOU ECTO A
LINE OF SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING- JULIE
AROUND UP WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE TO IN Q. WE JUST TO
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THIS SIX
LINE IS- OPEN. ONE SEVENTY ONE.
YES I'M MORE IN THIS EDUARDO
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND KIND OF WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT AND
INTENT OF AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JERRY BUXTON
THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
IN Q. THANK YOU HOW DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. OF LOOKING
THROUGH THIS BILL LIKE YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT I HAVE
WITH THAT ARE YOU KNOW IT'S
ANOTHER PROGRAM. THAT HAS GREAT
INTENTIONS. IF WE HAD THE
ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM WHICH
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
ESPECIALLY IN A DISTRICT LIKE
MINE- IS NOT- GONNA BE SOLVED
WITH BIKE A BIKE TRAILS IT IS
SIMPLY TOO WARM. OUT IN THOSE
AREAS TO BE ABLE TO FACILITATE
PEOPLE RIDING THEIR BIKES TO
THE EMPLOYMENT. BUT THE REAL
UNDER THE GET THE REAL
UNDERLYING PROBLEM IS THE
EMPLOYMENT PART OF THAT- IF YOU
WANT TO REDUCE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. THEN EMPLOYMENT NEEDS
TO BE- IN AREAS WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE. AND IN AREAS LIKE MINE.
WE HAVE 62% OF THE PEOPLE
COMMUTE TO ORANGE COUNTY OR SAN
DIEGO OR LA. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT TO BRING IN- JOB
PRODUCERS THAT MEANS BUSINESSES
CORPORATIONS THINGS LIKE THAT
THEY CAN HELP PEOPLE SUSTAINED-
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD A HOUSE IS
SIMPLY NOT THERE. I AND IN FACT
WE DON'T HAVE AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM WE HAVE A DISINCENTIVE
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO
AND I'M LESS WE ADDRESS THE
ISSUES WITH WITH NOT HAVING THE
JOB BASE THAT WE NEED IN THESE
OTHER AREAS THAT ARE GROWING-
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO SOLVE AND-
I FEEL LIKE WE'RE PILING THINGS
ON TO LOCAL AGENCIES TO KEEP
DOING PLANNING. FOR THINGS THAT
THEY CANNOT POSSIBLY IMPLEMENT.
BECAUSE WE SIMPLY ARE NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET INTO THE- IT GET
PAST THE PART THAT IS REALLY
BROKEN- SO IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
SUPPORT PILING ON LIKE THIS-
YOU KNOW THE BIKE LANE CONCEPT
I THINK CAN BE INCORPORATED IN
A LOT OF THESE EXISTING LIKE
THE METROPOLITAN AREAS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THEY HAVE PLENTY
OF ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN
BE CONVERTED TO BIKING FIRST IN
LINE INRASTRUCTURE. YOU DON'T
NEED CAL TRANSGENDER ACTOR THE
MONEY IN FROM. OUR ROAD- BILL.
THE THEY NEEDED CAN TO DO OUT
IN AREAS LIKE IN MY DISTRICT.
SO THE PEOPLE CAN GET AROUND
NOT JUST FROM FROM OUR AREA TO
OUTLYING COUNTIES.TO GET TO
GET TO WORK BUT JUST SO THEY
CAN GET AROUND TOWN SO THEY CAN
GET TO THE GROCERY STORE THEY
CAN GET TO THE NEIGHBORING
CITIES- SO- YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS IS. A GREAT FRIEND TO THE
LONG TERM FUTURE SOME DAY IF WE
CAN TAKE CARE THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS FIRST. AND UNTIL I SEE
THAT IT'S HARD FOR ME TO GET
BEHIND THESE THESE ARE THE TYPE
OF INITIATIVES THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU- MISTER FLORIDA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SOMEONE OVER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I DO OBVIOUSLY HAVE
SOME CONCERNS IN AND I CONCERT
IS REALLY IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS YOU AND I HAVE.
TRAVELED A LOT OF THE DOWN THE
STATE TOGETHER RECENTLY AND- IF
WE LOOK AT THAT CALIFORNIA WE
LOOK AT THE APPROACH OF THIS
BILL IS TAKING. IT'S ONCE AGAIN
IT SEEMS LIKE A VERY BROAD
STROKE. AND COMING FROM OUR
PARTICULAR AREA OF THE WORLD IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I KNOW THE
BILL STATES THAT MULTIPLE
COUNTIES TO WORK TOGETHER TO
CREATE THESE PLANS. BUT EVEN
THAT IS INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING
BUT I DO JUST HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION IN THE BILL LANGUAGE
IT TALKS ABOUT. REQUIRING
CALTRANS TO SUBMIT TO SEE- TO
SEE THIS IS. WHY I'M FOURTEEN
THAT PAGE FOUR OF MY OF THE
ANALYSIS- BEFORE JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALTRANS TO
SUBMIT TO CTC A PROPOSAL FOR
APPROVAL. PRESIDENTIAL ATP
FUNDING FOR A PILOT PROGRAM TO
ESTABLISH BRANDED NETWORKS A
BICYCLE HIGHWAYS. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH BICYCLE
HIGHWAYS. BUT IT ONE OF IN THE
SUBSECTION. IS SAYS RESTRICT
THAT USED TO THAT NETWORK TO
BICYCLISTS. ARE WE EVEN AT THIS
POINT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF VEHICLES RIGHT.
INTO LOW EMISSION THINGS
BICYCLES DOES THAT MEAN
SCOOTERS AND ALL SORTS OF OTHER
TYPES OF TRANSPORTATION WILL
NOT BE ALLOWED ON THESE BICYCLE
HIGHWAYS BECAUSE IN THE
LANGUAGES THAT RESTRICTS USE OF
THE NETWORK TO BICYCLISTS. SO I
JUST BE CURIOUS ABOUT THE CASE
WELL THANKS FOR THE QUESTION
AND LET ME SAY THAT. I KNOW
THAT THE BICYCLE PIECE OF THIS
SEEMS TO BE GETTING A LOT OF
ATTENTION BUT THE BILL IS NOT.
ABOUT BIKE LANES THE BILL IS
ABOUT PLANNING FOR JOBS FOR
HOUSING FOR MAKING LAND USE
DECISIONS THAT REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED THE BIKE PIECE
IS A PART OF IT. BUT THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT OF OTHER STUFF IN
HERE AND THREE SEVENTY FIVE SO
I WANT TO COME BACK TO THAT OF
MY CLOSING. BUT IN TERMS OF
THAT I THINK THAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT JUST THAT
PARTICULAR SECTION BUT WE CAN
pRIGHT AND BY THE WAY BYE BYE K.
WITH IT DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE
BUILDING. NECESSARILY AN
ELEVATED HIGHWAY IT MEANS TO
HAVE NETWORKS TO CONNECT TO
EACH OTHER. FOR EXAMPLE IN
GLENDALE WE SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY ON A BIKE LANE THAT'S
ABOUT A MILE AND A HALF IT
DOESN'T YET CONNECT TO THE L.
A. RIVER BIKE PATH IF YOU
CONNECT THEM YOU NOW HAVE A BUY
KILEY WHERE PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY
COMMUTE. USING THIS SYSTEM A
PROTECTED BIKE LANES BUT IF
THEY'RE NOT CONNECTED. THEY
BECOME SOMETHING THAT VERY FEW
PEOPLE CAN USE FOR PRACTICAL
REASONS OTHER THAN KIND OF
HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF
RECREATION. SO IT'S TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES TO
CONNECT TOGETHER SO THAT YOU'RE
CONNECTING YOUR RESIDENTIAL
PEOPLE WITH YOUR JOB CENTERS WE
CAN CERTAINLY FINESSE THE
LANGUAGE TO. MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
WHATEVER IS ALLOWABLE UNDER
THOSE YOU KNOW THOSE ORDINANCES
IF YOU'RE ALLOWED TO RIDE AN E.
BIKE. ON THE LANE MAYBE YOU CAN
DO IT MAYBE THERE'S A REASON
YOU WOULD WANT TO DO IT IN
CERTAIN PLACES BUT WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO BE THAT PRESCRIPTIVE
OR RESTRICTIVE WERE TRYING TO
LEAVE. IT UP TO INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE DIFFERENT
NEEDS AND ARE ARE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF COMMUNITIES TO FIND
THEIR OWN WAY TO REDUCE GHG
WITH IN THEIR OWN. WORLD IN A
VERY SUBURBAN COMMUNITY FOR
INSTANCE MAYBE YOU'RE NOT GONNA
BE BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
MAYBE YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ALLOWING. MORE THE FARMERS
MARKET SO THE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
TO DRIVE TO THE GROCERY STORES
ON SATURDAY THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE A PLAN THAT REDUCES
YOUR G. H. T. MAYBE YOU CHANGE
YOUR ZONING TO ALLOW PIANO
LESSONS IN A RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD OR CHIROPRACTORS
OR CORNER BODEGAS. THINGS THAT
GIVE PEOPLE A CHANCE OF MOVING
AROUND THEIR COMMUNITY WITHOUT
HAVING TO DRIVE LONG DISTANCES
THOSE ARE THE KIND I TO. THINGS
THAT ARE ELLA. WITHIN PLAN TO
SHOW THAT YOU'RE REDUCING.
MILES TRAVELED. IS TO TRY TO
MAKE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE. NOT
RURAL COMMUNITIES BUT BUDGETS
MORE METROPOLITAN. SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES. FOR THEM TO LOOK
AT THEIR OWN COMMUNITY AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT WOULD GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DRIVE. LESS HOW DO WE BRING
THOSE JOBS CLOSER TO HOUSING
HOW DO WE ALLOW FOR MORE USES.
REDUCE SPRAWL OR JUST FORCING
PEOPLE TO ALWAYS DRIVE JUST TO
GET A GALLON OF MILK. THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL IS ABOUT. THAT'S
WHY IT HAS TO BE BROUGHT IT HAS
TO BE BROAD BECAUSE YOU DON'T
WANT TO BE PRESCRIPTIVE IN THE
BILL. YOU WANT TO GIVE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES THE
CHANCE TO INNOVATE. AND TO DO
WHAT WORKS FOR THEIR COMMUNITY.
BUT THE GOALS ARE THE SAME
ACROSS THE STATE. FIND WAYS TO
GIVE PEOPLE CHANCES OF MOVING
AROUND THEIR COMMUNITY. IN WAYS
OTHER THAN CARS WHETHER IT'S BY
BIKES OR SCOOTERS. AND LOOK AT
YOUR OWN LAND USE TO SEE HOW
YOU'VE CREATED A BARRIER TO
WALKABILITY. NOT TO GET TOO FAR
OFF THE TOPIC I LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY WHERE I HAVE TO WALK
TWO MILES TO GET A GALLON OF
MILK. WHY CAN'T THERE BE A
CORNER BODEGA OR LITTLE GROCERY
STORE ALLOW ON THE MAIN DRAG IN
MY SUBURBAN NEIGHBORHOOD. MY
CITY DOESN'T ALLOW IT. SO THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF INTROSPECTIVE.
OF SELF LOOKING WE WANT OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BE THINKING
ABOUT AND THAT'S WHY IT IS
BROAD AND GOAL ORIENTED RATHER
THAN PRESCRIPTIVE AND WILL LOOK
AT THE LANGUAGE AROUND THE BIKE
HIGHWAYS FOR SURE. BE SURE YOU
BRING THAT UP TO MEXICO AND I
DIDN'T CATCH THAT THERE'S A
PARTICULAR REASON I DO AND WHO
HAS YOUR RIGHT THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS IN THIS BILL THAT.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU ON-
IN ONE OF MY IN LARGER CITIES
OF MY DISTRICT THEY DID THEY
CREATED A BIKE LANE BETWEEN A
JUNIOR COLLEGE. AND WE WANT
CAMPUS AND ANOTHER. NOBODY USES
IT. BUT THEY WERE REQUIRED TO
SPEND THE MONEY ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT SO IT HAD TO
BE DONE. AND LITERALLY NOBODY
USES IT BECAUSE TO YOUR POINT
THAT CONNECTS WITH NOTHING. I
MEAN THIS TO JUNIOR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. BUT PEOPLE DRIVE THEY
DON'T USE IT. SO IS GORGEOUS-
ESSENTIALLY WASTE OF MONEY FOR
A LOT OF WAYS AND NOW IT'S KIND
OF BEEN DOING LIKE THE HOMELESS
HIGHWAY THE ONLY PEOPLE YOU SEE
IT. ON IT IS HOMES PEOPLE
PUSHING A CART AROUND. THAT IS
NOT WHAT WE WANT TO DO HERE I'M
ASSUMING SO. IF THERE IS A
METHOD OR AND AN IDEA THAT WE
CAN ALLOW FOR LOCAL CONTROL. TO
ALLOW THOSE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO STATE
TO STATE. TO PUT A MANDATE OR
REQUIREMENT ON THE WE HAVE TO
DO THIS. THEN WE JUST DO STUPID
PROJECTS JUST TO CHECK A BOX
RIGHT SO EXPECT TO JUST
REMEMBER THAT WHAT THIS DOES IS
IT DOESN'T SPECIFY ANY TYPE OF
PROJECT THAT THE CITY HAS TO
DO. IT SAYS USE YOUR OWN
PLANNING YOU MUST PLAN TO DO
THIS IN A WAY THAT MAKES SENSE
FOR YOUR COMMUNITY. SO WE'RE
NOT FORCING THEM TO DO ANY
PARTICULAR. KIND OF PROJECT WE
THEY ALL HAVE THEIR CARDS THEY
ALL HAVE THEIR- THEIR COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS THEY ALL HAVE
THEIR REGIONAL. NETWORKS ALL
WE'RE SAYING IS WHEN YOU MAKE-YOUR PLANS. NTERNALLY AND
REGIONALLY. YOU MUST FIND WAYS
TO REDUCE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED IF THIS. THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT
PARTICULAR PLAN IF THEY DIDN'T
HAVE DATA SHOW WOULD ACTUALLY.
BE USEFUL THAT'S NOT ON THE
STATE WITH OUR GOALS THAT'S ON
THEM AND THEIR OWN INTERNAL
PLANNING. OR MAYBE MISSED
JUDGING OR MAY AB THERE SOME
OTHER VERY MAYBE IT IS. THE
HOMELESS. PEOPLE ARE. NOT TO
USE THE TRAIL I DON'T KNOW I
HAVE NO I. THERE'S A LOT YOU
KNOW BUT- BUT WE'RE JUST SAYING
TO CITIES WHEN YOU PLAN. PLAN
IN A WAY THAT GIVES PEOPLE MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET OUT OF THEIR
CARS WHATEVER WE WILL WORK FOR
YOUR COMMUNITY IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT WHEREVER YOU ARE. NOT
I PRESUME WE CAN HAVE THIS
ARMENIA TAKE MUCH MORE BUT I
APPRECIATE THE AYE LOOK I LOVE
THE DIALOGUE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I JUST SAID YOU KNOW I
AGAIN WOULD APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
THIS IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONNECT. OUR LAND USE
PLANNING. WITH OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS SCHOOLS. WE HAVE NOT DONE A
GOOD JOB WITH THAT IN THE STATE
AND THAT'S WHAT WITH THIS BILL
IS REALLY TRYING TO GET OUR
PLANNING AGENCIES TO THINK
ABOUT. AS THEY DO THEIR PLANTS.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN. SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
SECONDED BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD CAN I SAY ONE MORE THING
I'M SORRY I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING MICHAEL
JARED HER STAFFER TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BILL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND HIS
MUCH FOR ACKNOWLEDGING. MICHAEL
TO THE MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I AM TO
AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVERSIDE
FLORIDA FLORA NO CHILD FRIEDMAN
HI FRIEDMAN I'D GARCIA. MATHIS
MATHIS NO MCCARTY RIGHT TO G.
THIRTY KNOW SEROTONIN- STONE.
STONE I WOULD WOULD I. FOUR
ZERO HEY WE WILL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU I'M NEXT
IS AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE.
PLATE WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR EXCELLENT
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL.
GLOBALLY THE E. COMMERCE
INDUSTRY USES NEARLY TWO POINT
ONE BILLION WITH A B. POUNDS OF
PLASTIC PACKAGING OF THE THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY USE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND OF THAT
E. COMMERCE BUSINESSES IN THE
U. S. GENERATED FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE MILLION POUNDS
OF PLASTIC PACKAGING WASTE.
LAST YEAR CONSUMERS SPENT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS ONLINE WITH U. S.
MERCHANTS UP 44% OVER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WITH ALMOST A
THIRD OF THE WORLD'S POPULATION
NOW BUYING ONLINE THE AMOUNT OF
PLASTIC PACKAGING GENERATED IS
ESTIMATED TO DOUBLE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THIS STAGGERING
GROWTH EXPECTED TO OUTLAST THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
CREATING A WAVE OF SINGLE USE
PACKAGES AND PACKAGING ALMOST
ALWAYS HEADED FOR LANDFILL IF
WE'RE LUCKY A LOT OF IT GETS
INCINERATED OR ENDS UP
POLLUTING OUR WATERWAYS AND OUR
OCEANS. THIS PACKAGING IS
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY NON
RECYCLABLE AS AN ONLINE RETAIL
CONSUMER MYSELF AS MOST OF US
ARE I'M APPALLED AT THE AMOUNT
OF PLASTIC THAT COMES WITH
ITEMS YOU KNOW EVEN ITEMS THAT
DON'T NEED PLASTIC PACKAGING
AND OF GETTING WRAPPED IN GOBS
OF PLASTIC. VERY OFTEN. AND I
HEAR THIS FROM MY- RESIDENTS OF
MY CITY ALL THE TIME AND PEOPLE
THINK THAT IT'S RECYCLABLE AND
THEY PUT IN THEIR CURBSIDE
RECYCLING BIN AND IT'S NOT
CURBSIDE RECYCLABLE AND
ANYWHERE THAT I KNOW OF AND IT
BECOMES CONTAMINATION THAT
LITERALLY HAS TO BE SCOOPED OUT
OF ECYCLED MACHINES ON THE
HOUR IT'S REALLY REALLY A
PROBLEM AND- IT'S PRETTY
UNCONSCIONABLE ESPECIALLY SINCE
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES. THAT MUCH OF THE
INDUSTRY IS SHIFTING TO- THAT
ALREADY EXIST AND THAT ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED ELSEWHERE IN
FACT ALTERNATIVE PACKAGING LIKE
LIME LUPIN MUSHROOM MUSHROOM
PACKAGING MADE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IS ACTIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE WILL
REDUCE THE UNNECESSARY AND
UNACCEPTABLE AMOUNT OF SINGLE
USE PLASTIC PLASTIC USED AN E.
COMMERCE MARKETPLACE BY PHASING
IT OUT OVER TIME AND BY SENDING
THAT MARKET SIGNAL TO PEOPLE
WHO DEVELOP AND INNOVATE THESE
PRODUCTS. BUT THERE IS GOING TO
BE AN EVEN HUGER AND GROWING
MARKET FOR IT GIVING THE
RETAILERS TIME TO SHIFT OVER AS
YOU KNOW WITH THE NEED TO SHIFT
OVER CONTINUING THE WORK THAT
MANY OF THEM SUCH AS AMAZON
ALREADY DOING WITH SUSTAINABLE
PACKAGING THIS IS LOW HANGING
FRUIT MEMBERS AND SOMETHING
THAT IS. REALLY REALLY A
SCOURGE SO I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL TODAY I WITH
ME HERE TO TESTIFY ARE ACTUALLY
TRIGGER WITH OCEANIA THE
SPONSORED AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE AND LAUREN COLUMN THE
POLICYADVOCATE WITH SIERRA
CLUB. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE ALLOW
THE WITNESSES TO COLIN. GIVE
THEIR LINES ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ASHLEY DRINKER AND I
AM THE PACIFIC POLICY AND
COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER FOR THE
OCEAN CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION
OCEANA ON BEHALF OF OUR MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS OCEANIC PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
TO REDUCE THE HARMFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF UNNECESSARY
SINGLE USE PLASTIC PACKAGING.
USED FOR SHIPMENT SENT DIRECTLY
TO CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS FROM
ONLINE RETAIL PURCHASES. OR
E-COMMERCE. LAKE SUPPORT
EFFORTS LIKE AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE A SURVEY CONDUCTED
LAST SUMMER REVEALED THAT 85%
OF AN OF AMAZON CUSTOMERS IN
THE U. S. ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
PLASTIC POLLUTION. AND 71% WITH
NEW PLASTIC FREE ALTERNATIVE
PACKAGING OFFERED. THE GOOD
NEWS ABOUT PRACTICAL
ALTERNATIVES TO SINGLE USE
PLASTICS. AND FIRE FROM
PACKAGING ARE AVAILABLE IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY AMAZON INDIA
ANNOUNCED IT HAD ACHIEVED A
1100% SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION
AWAY FROM SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PACKAGING LESS THAN A YEAR
AFTER THEIR DECLARATIONS ACT.
AMAZON HAS ALSO DEVELOPED A
CURBSIDE RECYCLABLE PADDED
PAPER MILLER BEING USED IN THE
U. S. PROCESS THE ORDER. THE
GLOBAL ECOMMERCE LEADERS PRIOR
AND CURRENT ACTION TO ADDRESS
IT SINGLE USE PLASTICS PROBLEM
DEMONSTRATES WHAT IS POSSIBLE
WHEN PLASTIC REDUCTION AND THE
PRIORITY. ADDITIONALLY IF THERE
ARE U. S. MANUFACTURERS WHO
PRODUCE ALTERNATIVE TO SINGLE
SIX HUNDRED AT THE PLASTIC
CUSHIONING AND VOID FILL THAT
PROTECTED DURING SHIPMENT AND
THE ALTERNATIVE CAN AND SHOULD
BE USED MORE WIDELY. CALIFORNIA
MUST LEAD OUT OF THE WORLD WIDE
E. COMMERCE CONTINUES TO
INCREASE IN VOLUME IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE ESTABLISH
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE PACKAGES
SENT IN AND INTO THE STATE A
PACKAGE AS THE STATE EMPLOYEE
AND RESPONSIBLY AS POSSIBLE.
WITHOUT BOLD ACTION THE
PLASTICS CRISIS AND SUBSEQUENT
HARMFUL IMPACTS WILL ONLY
WORSEN. WITHOUT IMMEDIATE
CHANGES TO THE WAY WE USE
PLASTICS THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
PLASTIC WASTE GENERATED IN THE
CONNECTED TO DOUBLE AND THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. THE NEW MOTHER
ANNA CALIFORNIANS I FEEL
STRONGLY THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO TACKLE THIS
PRESSING ISSUE. WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR
LEADING AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE FOR CO AUTHORING.
EIGHTY THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE WE
URGE AND I ABOUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. I THINK
YOU'RE GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SPHERICAL CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING HALF A MILLION
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS STATE AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE GLOBAL PLASTICS
CRISIS BY PHASING OUT THE
UNNECESSARY AND UNACCEPTABLE
AMOUNT OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC
USED TO SHIP ONLINE PURCHASES
IN INTO CALIFORNIA. THIRTY
THREE BILLION POUNDS OF PLASTIC
INTO THE WORLD'S MARINE
ENVIRONMENT EVERY DEVASTATING
OUR SHARED OCEAN AND COASTAL
ECOSYSTEM NOT CLASSIC COULD NOT
GO AWAY HE SAID IT BREAKS UP
INTO SMALLER PIECES BUT THEN
STARBIRD CHOKE WILDLIFE
CLASSICS PROGRESS YOU CAN HELP
ON OUR QUALITY OF LIFE AND
CALIFORNIANS SIGNIFICANTLY
CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFE CYCLE AND
COST CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR TO CLEAN UP
AND PREVENT. FROM ENTERING OUR
OCEANS AND WATERWAYS. WHAT'S
THE MAILING ENVELOPE AIR
COOLERS PROBLEM. AND EXPAND
POLICY INCLUDING READ SPELL
COME REFERRED TO AS PART
INCLUDES. AND MOBILE PHONE
ADDED TO ONLINE BECAUSE DURING
SHIPMENT SUBSTANTIAL COULD. TO
THE CRISIS. BOB HI FOR PLASTIC.
USES MARKET MAY FROM THE OF THE
CLASS FOR GENERATIONS ALMOST
ALL THE PACKAGES FISCAL
IMMEDIATELY OUT CRAPPIE OPEN.
AND NEED TO RE USED NOR CARGO.
I THINK IT BECOMES LAND. BURNED
OR INTEREST ON MEANS PUT AT THE
PUMP GENERAL. EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE EVEN. URGENT
THEY'LL INTO ADDRESSING THAT.
WAY STREAMS WE IS A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR LEADERS AND- YOUR
EYES THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
HAVE TO WAIT A OFFICE. OF
MODERATOR KEEP ALLOW. TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU THEIR LINES ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE MATTER AND
MEMBERS. SORRY ADAM GO HEAD.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AUTOMATICALLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION I WANNA
BEGIN BY PROVIDING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WANTED COMPREHENSIVE RECYCLING
POLLUTION AND TO THAT END OF
THE WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YEARS NOW AN
IMPLEMENTABLE THICK THAT I
CREATE ROBOT AND MARKET. HOLD
BUSINESSES ACCOUNTABLE DESIGN
FOR RECYCLABILITY INCENTIVIZE
SOURCE REDUCTION AND PROVIDE
FUNDING AND A PATHWAY TO BRING
MUCH NEEDED RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE ONLINE IN
CALIFORNIA. A LOT OF ONE TEN OF
EIGHTY THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
DIFFERENT OUR NAPA ENVIRONMENT.
WE BELIEVE THE BILL MISSES THE
MARK AT PROVIDING MEANINGFUL
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS EXCEPT
WEIGHT. REDUCING POLLUTION IN
OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. ALL
GOALS WHICH CALCHAMBER AND ITS
COALITION PARTNER SHARE WITH
THE AUTHOR. BUT BY PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS IN THE
PACKING STATE WITHOUT A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH OR
LOOKING AT THE FULL LIFE CYCLE
IMPACT WILL BE MATERIAL. THE
BILL AND ARGUE ARBITRARILY
BANNED MATERIALS FOR BOTH LARGE
AND SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT MANY
CASES HAVE NO COMPATIBLE
SUBSTITUTE. WE BELIEVE THIS
WILL LEAD TO GREATER NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL EXTERNALITIES AND
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTIONS TO
GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN. NUMEROUS
LIFE CYCLE ANALYSES SHOW THE
VERY PACKAGING MATERIALS BANNED
BY THIS BILL ACTUALLY HAVE
LOWER NET CARBON EMISSIONS.
LOWER FOSSIL FUEL UAGE LOWER
WATER USAGE WHEN COMPARED TO
OTHER PACKAGE FORMATS. THE
PACKAGING SERVICE SEVERAL
CRITICAL FUNCTIONS IN OUR
MODERN ECONOMY THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT RECOGNIZE. I'M SHOULD
BE TELEVISION MONITORS LARGE
APPLIANCES TO INSURANCE FRUITS
VEGETABLES AND RAW MEAT
PRODUCTS ALL PHYSICALLY ARRIVE.
THESE MATERIALS BANNED UNDER
THIS BILL PLAYED CENTRAL ROLES
ENSURING THAT THE FACT THAT
COULD ARRIVE SAFELY AND THAT
THE FOOD SHELF LIFE IS
PROLONGED TO AVOID EXCESS
WEIGHT AND CARBON EMISSIONS. TO
THAT END WE BELIEVE THE BILL IS
ACTUALLY INCONGRUENT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES. TO REDUCE GHG
EMISSIONS ACROSS ALL SECTORS.
CALCHAMBER MEMBERS ARE
CONTINUOUSLY LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO OPTIMIZE SHIPPING REDUCE
COSTS. AND REDUCE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE LEGISLATURE ON A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO
INCREASING RECYCLING OF
PACKAGING MATERIALS. WHILE ALSO
ENSURING NEED GOOD MOVE
EFFICIENTLY AND SAFELY. FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DANTE.
WITH MCCUE K. UNITS ON THE TO
CAL MANY. AND TECHNOLOGY IF IT.
ALSO RESPECT OPPOSITION TO AB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE. C. M.
CANIS MEMBERS THAT INCREASED
EFFORTS ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE
PACKAGING MATERIAL IS
RECYCLABLE AND APPROPRIATELY
RECOVERED AND RECYCLED. TO THAT
END SEEMED UNITS MEMBERS AND
SPENT THE BETTER PART OF THE
LAST THREE YEARS WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR COLLEAGUE
ORGANIZATIONS. DEVELOPING A
WORKABLE FRAMEWORK FOR THE
RECOVERY AND RECYCLING OF
SINGLE USE PACKAGING MATERIALS
AS WELL AS EFFORTS TO DEVELOP
POLICIES AND PROVIDE YOU
DOMESTIC MARKETS FOR RECYCLED
MATERIALS. IMPROVED PACKAGING
DESIGNED TO INCREASE
RECYCLABILITY CAN DEVELOP
VALUES YOU FINANCING FOR
COLLECTING AND SORTING VARIOUS
PACKAGING FORMAT. WEALTHY
IMPAIR PRESHEAF THE INTENT OF
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE CM
BELIEVES THAT THE COURT
SUPPLEMENT TO PAY THAT TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT THE NECESSARY BOLD
PACKAGING PLAYS IN SHIPPING AND
PROTECTING PRODUCTS. ADOPTED
THE MULTITUDE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ATTRIBUTES SUCH AS
RECYCLABILITY WASTE PREVENTION
MATERIALIZATION THE ANDY
GRIFFITH HOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
RELATED TO THE VARIOUS
PACKAGING MATERIALS. AND ARRIVE
AT A SOLUTION THAT MAKES SENSE
OF OUR MENTALLY WHILE PROVIDING
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY AND
BROADER SUPPLY CHAIN. WITH
PRACTICAL AND IMPLEMENTABLE
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS THE
RECORDING REQUIREMENTS
UNFORTUNATELY AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE INCLUDES BANDS ON
SOME PACKAGING MATERIALS USED
FOR SHIPPING THAT THEY HAVE TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. AND IN FACT COULD VERY
WELL LEAD TO INCREASED WASTE AS
A RESULT OF PRODUCT BREAKAGE
FOR SPOILAGE CHAMPAGNAT MEMBERS
UNDERSTANDABLE THEY NEED TO
TWENTY INCREASING RECOVERING
PRODUCTION AND RECYCLING OF YOU
SINGLE USE PACKAGING WASTE PUT
INTO THE MARKETPLACE. TO THAT
END GMG WILL WORK TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IAN LEGISLATURE
CRAFT AN APPROACH THAT IS
WORKABLE AND IMPLEMENTABLE TO
ADDRESS THESE GOALS RATHER THAN
THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
PROHIBITION UNDER AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. THAT IS LIKELY TO
INCREASE WASTE AND NEGATIVELY
IMPACT CALIFORNIA BASED
MANUFACTURERS TO MANUFACTURE
AND USE SUCH PACKAGING. FOR
THESE REASONS THE CMJ MUST
RESPECTFULLY REMAIN OPPOSED TO
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE AND
UNFORTUNATELY. MUCH
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE
WILL OPEN THE UP TO WITNESSES
ON THE LINE. AND SOME OR A-
THANK YOU YOU ARE SUPPORT OR
THE OF AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
YOU MY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING HERE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
FOOD SAFETY AND THE CLEAN SEIZE
COALITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT TO A LINE OF FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIVE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI BONNIE BY
ALL OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
MORNING CHAIRMAN BURKE
PREFERRED DOCTOR ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL HAS THE
SUPPORT OF AMENDED PETITION IN
COURT THE AUTHOR TO INCREASE
THE PENALTY FROM ABOUT I
LANGUAGE THAT CLARIFIES THAT
PLASTIC BAGS CANNOT BE RECYCLED
AT CURB THANK YOU. FOR TO
WORKING AT YOUNGER FONG
ANYTHING I THINK THE MEMBER FOR
IN IN THE IMPORTANT THINGS YOU.
I JUST WONDER. OF TO YOUR NAME-
I FELT. AS POSITION ON THE-
YOUR NECK SILVA LINE OF EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF
US SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY GOOD MORNING THIS IS
THIRTY YEARS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE IF THE PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. DO NOT
SO WELL I KNOW SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHE MARRIED
BUXTON THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
TO GOAL LINE OF SEVENTY ONE
YOU'RE LINUS. I'M SORRY EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CRISTINA WALK WITH RECOLOGY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
LINE OF EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY BACK
ABOUT THEM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
WITH THAT AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER A LINE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PAN AM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOE ADLER ON BEHALF
OF THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO RAIN ALAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE
OF EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BRAINY POLLOCK AND BE
HAPPY THE MERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
NINETY TWO MY NAME IS ANDREA
HEDSTROM AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE INSULTED
THAT YOU ARE KEEPING US OUT OF
THE BUILDING AND YOU'RE
QUIBBLING ABOUT PLASTIC I AM
STRONGLY IN. OPPOSITION TO AB
NUMBER THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
QUIT MESSING ABOUT OPEN THE
BUILDING AND CANNOT TELL THE
NEXT. LEASE THANK YOU WILL GO A
LINE OF EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MARIN AGUILAR
BEHALF OF AMERICAN IN THE
FLEXIBLE PACKAGING ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
THE NEXT OF A LINE OF EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
GAIL BILL HANCE WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS
PRODUCE AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING BE ANY CRACKDOWN ON THE
HAPPY TECH NOT IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND MEDICARE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU- ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM. C. NINE DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. OKAY THERE
ARE NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OKAY
MISTER WHAT. WELL THANK YOU- IS
WRITTEN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND I PLAN TO SUPPORT
IT AND DID HAVE A QUESTIONS
I'VE HEARD HEARD THIS REPEATED
A COUPLE OF TIMES YOU TALK
ABOUT ONLINE RETAILERS IS THE
FOCUS YOUR BILL YEAH WE'RE
HEARING FROM PEOPLE SERVICE
SHIPPING VEGETABLES AND MEATS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT CAN YOU
CLARIFY THAT. FOR US PLEASE
THANK YOU THIS IS E. COMMERCE
ONLY THIS DOES NOT AFFECT OF
FOOD BEING SHIPPED FROM A FARM
TO A GROCERY STORE GROCERY
STORE GOING TO RESTAURANTS IT
DOESN'T AFFECT ANY OF THAT THIS
IS WHEN YOU AS A CONSUMER.
ORDER SOMETHING AND JUST TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE I DID HEAR IT
FROM ONE OF THE- SPEAKERS IT'S
ALSO ONLY LARGE ONLINE SHOPPERS
WE WERE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
THRESHOLDS IS NOT YOUR EBAY
SELLERS YOU'RE AT C. SELLERS-
AND- SO YES IT IS MORE LIMITED
WELL AS WELL THANK YOU I THINK
ABOUT THE CERTAINLY DURING
COVERT THE THINGS IT ARRIVED AT
MY HOUSE AND THAT THAT DIDN'T
NEED TO BE IN PLASTIC YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT. A
CELLPHONE CASE MEANT TO PROTECT
THE CELLPHONE ARRIVES IN
PLASTIC BUBBLE WRAP AND IT'S
KIND OF LUDICROUS AND I GET IT
I GET I SEE WHAT THE ONLINE
RETAILERS ARE DOING THEIR THEIR
PRESS TO DO EVERYTHING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AS EASILY
AS POSSIBLE. BUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OR ARE HOPEFULLY
NOT INTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT TO OUR ENVIRONMENT ARTS OR
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. SO I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. OKAY I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD- AND I'D
LIKE TO JOIN YOU AS A CO AUTHOR
OF THE BILL THANK YOU WOULD BE
HONORED TO HAVE YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
WOULD. I'LL GO AHEAD AND SECOND.
ON THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
YOUR DISH TO DO SHERRY
COMMITTEE. WELL ACTUALLY LET ME
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ALL SAY
THAT I JUST WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT THESE MATERIALS ARE
NOT RECYCLABLE WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF TIME TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES
AVAILABLE AND IT MAY BE CHEAPER
FOR CONSUMERS ARE FOR SHIPPERS
TO DO THIS BUT THE PEOPLE WHO
PAY ARE THE ONES AT THE
RECEIVING END. THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE TO DEAL WITH ALL OF
THIS NON RECYCLABLE WASTE AND
WITH WASTE CLOGGING UP THEIR
RECYCLE CENTERS THAT IS- A
CONTAMINANT SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY OF SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM THREE
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORIDA. LARA NO CHILD FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI THEY ARE CHAU NO SE
R. TONO STONE. WOOD WOOD I.
FOUR THREE. CHANGE WE HAVE FOUR
THREE AND WE WILL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL. I'M NEXT WE HAVE.
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND START WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF PERMISSION TO USE A
FEW PROPS IF THAT'S OKAY. YES
GO AHEAD. BECAUSE. IS ALL OF
THEM THAT ARE VERY FAMILIAR TO
US THAT WE SEE EVERY EVERY
WEEKEND TO GO TO THE GROCERY
STORE. OF ALL. POSTERS SO FIRST
LET ME JUST BOTH THE
HUMANITARIAN COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH THIS ON
THIS BILL WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL
THE AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY THE
COMMITTEE BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE WILL NOT BE ADOPTED TO
THE MOVE- TO THE BILL MOVES
INTO THE NEXT COMMITTEE. AB
FOUR SEVEN THE STEPS THE TIME
FRAME FOR THERMOFORMED FOOD
PACKAGING MANUFACTURES TO USE
MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT IN THE
PLASTIC CONTAINER STARTING WITH
10% RECYCLED CONTENT IN 202420%
AND TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN AND 30%
BY TWENTY THIRTY THERMOFORM
FOOD CONTAINERS ALSO KNOWS THAT
KNOWN AS CLAM SHELLS WHICH ARE
THE CLAM SHELLS THAT YOU SEE
HERE. THE FREQUENTLY USED AS
PACKAGING FOR BERRIES AND-
GREEN TO TAKE OUT CONTAINERS
YOU CAN SEE LET ME JUSTSHOW
YOU A PICTURE YOU CAN SEE THE
SUB TO WASTE THAT OCCURS BUT TO
MILLION POUNDS OF THE REFORM
WHICH DISCARDED EACH YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST PICTURE IS
ALL FOR ALL OF US TO OUR
CURRENT DRINKERS. THIS IS WHAT
A LANDFILLS FILLED WITH CURRENT
COPS LOOKS LIKE SO THIS IS WHAT
THE CORRUPT COPS COP THAT'S
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IN A
LANDFILL- BECAUSE CURRENTLY
THEY ARE NOT RECYCLABLE EVEN
THOUGH PEOPLE THINK THAT THEY
MAY BE HI THIS IS THROUGHOUT
THE DAY THIS IS A TYPICAL
PICTURE FOR A LOT OF US IF YOU
GO TO THE BEACH- YOU SEE ALLOW
THE RED SOLO CUPS OF RED SOLO
CUPS WHICH I KNOW A LOT OF
THIS. PURCHASE HAVE AT HOME-
ARE VERY VERY COMMONLY LEFT ON
THE BEACH OR THE PARK AND THE
THESE ARE ALSO ANOTHER FORM OF
THERMOFORM SO THESE ARE THESE
ARE ITEMS THAT WE ARE WORKING
TO TRY TO GET TO ACTUALLY BE
RECYCLED- RIGHT NOW THESE
PRODUCTS AREN'T RECYCLED AND-
WE THINK THAT- BUILDING ON A
BILL FROM MASTERS MAY BE SEVEN
NINETY THREE THAT WE CAN.
REALLY MOVE THE MARKET AND
CREATE A CIRCULAR ECONOMY FOR
THIS SO- TWO WITNESSES BOB THE
DAVID DUCK WAS CEO OF- OUR
PLANET EARTH AND THAT SCOTT
WILKERSON WITH THE- DEL FRESH
AMERICANS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR CAN YOU ALLOW WITNESS
AND. HOME FOR THE- AIRLINES ARE
OPEN. K. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHIU THIS MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
W. CAN ON THE FOR AND THE SPEED
OF THE OUR POINT EARTH. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S MEETING
AND WE ARE PROUD TO BE THE
SPONSOR OF AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT.
OUR PLANET EARTH IS THE WORLD'S
FIRST COMPLETELY VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED MANUFACTURER. OF
RECYCLED P. E. T. ALSO KNOWN AS
OUR PACK PACKAGING AND OTHER
PRODUCTS- DERIVED FROM POST
CONSUMER PET CONTAINERS LOAD
BOTTLED THEM FROM A FORMS.
RECYCLED UP WAKE FORM A CONVERT
INTO NEW PRODUCTS INCLUDING
THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS AND OUR
THREE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
FACILITY LOCATED IN BURNING
CALIFORNIA. GEN SEEMS HIGHER
MANNER MANUFACTURE PROCESS
OCCURS UNDER SINGLE WORD. IN
THE HOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR PRODUCTS
ARE AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE
WORLD. DON'T WANT CONTAINERS
ARE USED IN MANY APPLICATIONS
OTHER THAN PACKAGING FOR FRESH
PRODUCE. IN STORES THERE USE
THAT DALY COUNTERS FOR ITEMS
SUCH AS SANDWICHES. PACKAGED
ITEMS SUCH AS NUTS AND DRIED
FRUITS. GUACAMOLE HUMMUS SALSA
AND IN MANY OTHER PRODUCTS. IN
ADDITION RESTAURANT USEFUL
FORMS FOR TAKEAWAY FOOD. OTHER
ITEMS SUCH AS DRINKING CUPS ARE
WIDELY USED IN HIGH VOLUME
APPLICATIONS AT EATING AND
DRINKING ESTABLISHMENTS
SPORTING EVENTS SO OF AND ANY
PARTY. THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED MILLION POUNDS OF
POST CONSUMER PET NORMAL FORM-
CONTAINERS DISCARDED IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR. AND ONE
OTHER PLASTIC THAT YOU'RE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT SUCH AS
POLYPROPYLENE THAT NUMBER IS
LIKELY CLOSER TO THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION POUNDS PER
YEAR AND GROWING. AT THE SAME
TIME THE RECYCLED PLASTIC
MARKET FACES MULTIPLE CRITICAL
CHALLENGES. DROPS IN OIL PRICES
HAVE RESULTED IN A LOW COST
VIRGIN PLASTICS. REDUCING
INCENTIVES FOR MANUFACTURERS TO
USE RECYCLED PLASTIC. AB FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT WILL COVER MOST
THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS USED
FOR FOOD AND BEVERAGES.
INCLUDING ITEMS SUCH AS PRODUCE
AND VERY CLAM SHELL CONTAINERS
SANDWICH CONTAINERS YOUR CUP
COFFEE PODS- ON TAKEOUT
CONTAINERS AND CURRENTLY TOPS.
AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT MOKRI
MARKET THE MAN FOR MATERIAL
THAT THE MOST PART IS BEING
LANDFILLED TODAY. AND IT IS A
CLOSED LOOP SOLUTION.
MANUFACTURING NEED STABILITY
WHICH IS WHY AB FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT IS NEEDED IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE MARKET DEMAND. AND TO
INCENTIVIZE COLLECTION OF RAW
MATERIAL FEEDSTOCK. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS MEASURE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR RIVAS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM SCOTT WILKERSON
AND I AM THE CHIEF PROCUREMENT
OFFICER AT BONDUELLE FRESH
AMERICAS BASED IN IRWINDALE AND
SALINAS CALIFORNIA YOU PROBABLY
KNOW IT AS READY PAC FOODS IN
YOUR LOCAL STORES WE ARE ONE OF
THE LARGEST US COMPANIES FOR
PRE PREPARED SALADS AND FRESH.
PRODUCE PRODUCTS. CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO SET THE PACE FOR
THE REST OF THE NATION AS THE
COUNTRY'S LARGEST AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCER AND EXPORTER.
THERMOFORM PACKAGING SUCH AS
CLAM SHELLS HAS REVOLUTIONIZED
THE ABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
FARMERS TO TRANSPORT THEIR
FRESH PRODUCE TO CONSUMERS
NATIONWIDE. THIS TYPE OF
PACKAGING HELPS EXTEND PRODUCT
LIFE AND PROTECT THE PRUDE
PRODUCE FROM DAMAGING
CONTAMINATION AND IT REDUCES
FOOD WASTE. PRODUCTS AND
PACKAGING MADE WITH POST
CONSUMER RECYCLED CONTENT ARE
INCREASINGLY A GLOBAL PRIORITY
FOR THE WORLD'S LARGEST
CONSUMER BRANDS AND RETAILERS.
OUR COMPANY OBJECTIVE IS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO HAVE
1100% OF OUR PACKAGING DESIGNED
TO BE RECYCLABLE OR REUSABLE
OUR COMPANY HAS MADE FIRM
COMMITMENTS TO USE RECYCLED P.
E. T. THERMOFORMED AND OUR
PRODUCTS. PREVIOUSLY MOST
RECYCLED P. E. T. HAS COME FROM
PLASTIC BOTTLES WHICH ARE
INCREASINGLY IN HIGH DEMAND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PASSAGE OF
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY THREE WHICH
SETS MINIMUM CONTENT I'M
PLASTIC BEVERAGE CONTAINERS. WE
ARE PLEASED BY THE SUCCESS OF
THE RECYCLING INDUSTRY TO MAKE
THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS FROM
THERMAL FOR MATERIALS WHICH IS
NOT AN EASY FEAT. HOWEVER WE
ARE FACED WITH THE CHALLENGE
WHERE COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
CURRENTLY COLLECTING
THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS I NOTS
TO SUPPORT ADEQUATE RECYCLING
RATES IN SUPPLY. WE ARE IN
SCHOOL SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT BECAUSE IT WILL
HELP TO ENSURE THAT THE
PACKAGING THAT WE USE NEEDS OUR
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS YOU COULD
RECYCLE CONTENT MANDATE. THIS
BILL IS NEEDED TO CREATE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WE HAVE
MADE INVESTMENTS IN RECYCLABLE
PRODUCT THAT ALSO HAS RECYCLED
CONTENT AND THIS BILL WILL
PROPEL THE WHOLE SUPPLY CHAIN
TOWARD MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE PACKAGING. WE WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
FOR CARRYING THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU- NEXT
WE HAVE A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- SHANNON CRAWFORD
FROM THE PLASTIC. PLASTICS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME IS SHANNON CRAWFORD AND
I'M HERE AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
NEARLY SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA TO WORK IN INDUSTRY
I'M JUST TRYING TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS WITH. EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
I REMEMBER STRONGLY SUPPORT BE
USE OF RECYCLED CONTENT. WE ARE
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO
MANUFACTURING PRODUCTS THAT
MEET THE ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL.
GEMMER INCLUSION OF PCR NUMBER
WRITING A PRODUCT CAN HAVE
POSITIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS. AND LEGISLATING
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS MAY BE
BENEFICIAL IF DONE
APPROPRIATELY. OUR MEMBERS
VOLUNTARILY BEGUN INCORPORATING
RECYCLED CONTENT INTO THEIR
PACKAGING. WHAT VEHICLE WOULD
DEVELOP AND MARKET YOUR PLASTIC
MATERIALS THERE SHOULD BE AN
EAGLE AT THE SECOND CRISTINA
COLLECTION SORTATION THE
VENTURE GET MORE OF THE- MARKET.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR KNOWLEDGE
INDICATE THERE WILL NOT
SUFFICIENT RECYCLE CONTENT YOU
NEED TO MANDATE THAT BUDGET. WE
DON'T WORK WITH IT COMMITTEE
AND I STAKEHOLDERS TO THE THEIR
OF RECYCLED. EIGHT THAT. ONE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER GONNA GET
YOU OF. CON ENGINE CONTACT
MATERIALS SHOULD TAKE A REGULAR.
JUST WEEK OUR INDICATION
RELEASED IN THAT INSURANCE
EVERYTHING PLASTIC PACKAGING
MEAT ANYTHING. COMPLIANCE FOR.
SEVERAL U. S. RIGHT. I'M NOT
WITH THE BALLOT OVER NEXT. TWO
YEAR PRICE. USUALLY WE ARE
WORKING ON BEST- SERVICE
COUNTRY AGING FACTORY SHE MIGHT
NEED TO BE END OF YOUR-
THINKING THINKING YEAH BETWEEN
HOW RECYCLE CONTENT. AND
REQUIRE AND- WE SHOULD CHEN
SUCH WHICH THE GOAL THIS
COMMITTEE FOCUS ADVANCED.
COLLECTION. NORTHWEST
DEMONSTRATION WITH INDUSTRY.
BUT SHOWS. STORY YOU CURRENTLY
IN EMAIL OF RECYCLE MATERIAL
AFTER. THE BROTHERS WORKING
BEAT THE YOUR CREATION BY
MARKET I. WILL BE HAPPY TO WITH
THIS COMMITTEE OTHER STATES TO
ADVANCE TO THAT INCREASE
AVAILABILITY RECYCLE. EIGHT
THANK YOU FOR TIME A POOR ANY
PLAY YOU MAY. THANK YOU NEXT
WILL TAKING. ADDITIONAL WAY.
ARE BOTH IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
A MOD CAN YOU WILL UP THE LINE.
YES THANK YOU IF YOU ARE OR UP
AND- AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO OUR FIRST LINE OF
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT
LEVEL LINE OF NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I THOUGHT YOU
DON'T ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS YOUR SHIP COUNCIL AND
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU XO GOAL LINE OF
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THEIR CUT CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LEVEL LINE OF
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND SUPPORT I
DON'T LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR THE QUEEN YOU LOBBYING
COALITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
APOLOGY ON BEHALF OF THE
THERMOFORM ALLIANCE WITH THE
WORKING WITH THE FARMERS AND
THE RECYCLERS REPRESENTING OUR
PLANET EARTH- BONDUELLE READY
TO PACK THESE BIG INK AND GREEN
IMPACT IN BOARD. OF. FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT GOAL LINE
OF NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
NUMBER THANK YOU WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT TO A LINE OF ONE OH ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF ONE OH THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JEFF DONLEVY
MEANS RECYCLING SACRAMENTO
INNINGS RESOURCES IN HAYWARD WE
SUPPORT AB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE BOTTLE
BILL AMENDED TO CHANGE THE
DEFINITION OF CO MINGLED NEXT
WHAT TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU WELL THE
LINE OF EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE NOT YOU ARE
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HUBER
PACKAGING ON THE ENVIRONMENT
AND THE PACKAGING ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY-
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES THAT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION.
THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE ANY-
SO I WOULD OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DO ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS.
OKAY MISTER SEATTLE- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KING FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- SO I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GONNA BE
TAKING EMISSIONS AND AMENDMENTS
AND THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE YES
AND I WAS CURIOUS IF THE ONE OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS MIGHT OFFER-
CAL RECYCLE THE SAME
FLEXIBILITY I TO ADJUST THE
GOAL AS YOU HAD IN AB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. NO I DON'T- HAVE.
THAT I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS
ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKING SO LET ME GET BACK TO
ENOUGH AND THE REASON I ASK
THAT IS BECAUSE A IN DEALING
WITH- MANY OF THE OTHER
MANDATES THAT HAVE BEEN HANDED
DOWN IN REGARDS TO RECYCLING
WHICH I THINK MOST MOST PEOPLE
SUPPORT RECYCLING. WHEN THE AND
GAME CAN'T BE ACHIEVED. BUT
WE'RE STILL RAMMING THINGS DOWN
THE THROATS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND ALSO THE WASTE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE TRYING TO.
TRYING TO ACHIEVE BUT JUST
CAN'T BECAUSE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT THERE
YET- CAL RECYCLED HANS IT
CONSISTENTLY- REFERS BACK TO
THE FACT THAT DOUBLES WE HAVE
NO FLEXIBILITY. AND SO THAT DID
IT TO ME I THINK THESE THINGS
NEED TO HAVE THAT IN AND SO.
I'LL I'LL YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY WE
CAN. I I'M I'M GONNA COME FROM
THE NO I STAFF IS. WATCHING SAW
WAIT TO SEE IF I GET A TEXT IF
WE CAN GET THAT FLEXIBILITY TO
GO A LONG WAYS TOWARDS. YOU
KNOW. PROBABLY LEAVE ANY ANY OF
THOSE THOSE TYPE OF CONCERNS
FROM ME. R. OR PROBABLY EVEN MY
COLLEAGUES AND- HERE TO GATHER
PROBABLY LAY OFF THIS BILL
UNTIL WE SEE WHAT. WHAT WHAT
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE ANY OF
THOSE CONCERNS ARE MEDIATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY.
HOWEVER MATHIS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. MISTER I DO A- WHERE
YOU'RE TRYING TO GO IN- MY
COLLEAGUE- A LOT OF US VERY
CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT THESE
AMENDMENTS. ARE GONNA END UP
BEING AS A MOVES FORWARD- SO I
TOO WILL BE LAYING OFF UNTIL WE
SEE. THE AFFORD TO SEE THAT
LOOKS LIKE IF YOU HELP WITH-
LOVE TO TALK TO YOU OFFLINE.
FORGET THE YOU. CAN SOMEONE.
THANK YOU HAS THIS BILL THEN IT.
YES YEAH SO I. SUPPORT THIS AND-
STATUS QUO IS THE NEXT AND I
THINK THAT SETS AN IMPORTANT-
MARKER FOR WHERE WE WANT TO GO
AND JUST THIS ASKING FOR TWO
REASONS ONE WE ALL SEE WAY TOO
MUCH PLASTIC ON OUR BEACHES ARE
PARKS. IT ON OUR ON OUR STREETS
AND OUR COMMUNITIES- MISS GOES
BACK TO THE BILL WE HEARD
SECOND EAGLE AS WELL FROM
SOMEONE NUMBER FRIEDMAN. BUT
THE BIGGER ISSUE IS I THINK
THERE'S BEEN THIS FRAUD PUT
UPON THE CONSUMERS FOR THE PAST
TWO DECADES THAT BELIEVING.
THANK YOU PUT EVERYTHING IN THE
IN THE BLUE PEN AND IT'S ALL
GOOD YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
SYMBOL. IN THE INDUSTRY TALKS
ABOUT RECYCLE AND RESURFACE TO
RECYCLE AND- CONSUMERS. TAKE DO
SO MUCH SO WE HAD A BIG SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THIS A FEW MONTHS
AGO- IN THE AMOUNTS OF THIS
INFORMATION FOR THE PUBLIC TO
THINKS THAT THINKS THAT THE
CURRENT CONTAINERS ARE SO MUCH
OF THEIR PLASTIC THAT. EXCEL
CONTAINERS OR FRUIT THEY PUT
HIM IN THE BLUE THEN GO TO SOME
MAGIC PLACE. AND IT'S GONNA
RECYCLE THAT'S NOT THE CASE AND
SO WE NEED TO HAVE A REALITY
CHECK. AND BASED ON THE
WORLDWIDE MARKET CONDITIONS AND
THIS AND- AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
TIME THAT WE GET MORE BOLDNESS.
AND SO THIS CERTAINLY IS THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD THE MOTION. IS DUE PASSED
TO. JUDICIARY MISTER KING I'M
SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WHAT JUST I THINK ALL DODD I
JUST DON'T ALIGN MYSELF WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO THINK
HE SAID IT REALLY WELL THAT WE
SEE THESE PRODUCTS EVERY DAY- I
KNOW I PUT IN MY BLUE BIN AT
HOME AND I YOU KNOW EVEN THE
WHOLE AND HOLE- THEY'RE NOT
GETTING RECYCLED BUT I THINK WE
WERE ALL LED TO BELIEVE THAT
THESE ARE RECYCLABLE ITEMS.
WHEN ALMOST NONE OF THESE ITEMS
ARE EVER RECYCLING TO LANDFILL
SO AGAIN I THINK THIS SETS UP A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY REALLY
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
JUST RESPECT FOR US FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU. SECRETARY Q. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T FIVE AB
FOR SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVAS III FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING CHAU. FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA. MATHIS
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY HI
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI THEY ARE
CHAU. CERTONA VOTING STONE
STONE I WOULD WOULD I. FIVE
ZERO A FIVE ZERO THAT WILL
ROUTE WILL REMAIN ON CALL. NEXT
WE HAVE EIGHTY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT. THANK YOU. YEAH
HERE'S MY COLLEAGUE HAS A LOT
OF PLASTIC MOVE HERE OF SOUTH
WE'RE TAKING. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AB
NINE CODIFIES THE REGIONAL
FOREST AND FIRE CAPACITY
PROGRAM OR THE R. F. R. F. F.
C. PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY AT THE DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION. THE PROGRAM JUST
RECEIVED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND EARLY ACTION BUDGET BUT
EARLY BUDGET ACTION FOR
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS IT WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
YESTERDAY. CALIFORNIA HAS A
NUMBER OF GRANT PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE- STATE GOVERNMENT- THAT
PROVIDES RESOURCES FOR FIRE
PREPAREDNESS PROJECTS
UNFORTUNATELY NEARLY ALL THESE
PROGRAMS ARE COMPETITIVE GRANTS
WHICH TYPICALLY DON'T PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR PROJECT PLANNING OR
DEVELOPMENT. AS A RESULT WE
FUND PROJECTS THAT ARE SHOVEL
READY BUT MAY NOT BE THE MOST
PRETTY JACK WERE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY FOR COMMUNITY AND FIRE
AND RESOURCE FIRE PROTECTION.
THE R. F. F. C. PROGRAM IS
UNIQUE BECAUSE IT WILL PROVIDE
FLEXIBLE BLOCK GRANTS TO
REGIONAL ENTITIES THAT WILL
CREATE A REGIONAL PLAN AND
DEVELOP A PIPELINE OF FIRE
PREPAREDNESS PROJECTS AND MEET
THAT MEETS THE SPECIFIC NEEDS
OF THE REGION. ONCE DEVELOP THE
PROJECTS IN THE PIPELINE WILL
BE WELL POSITIONED TO
SUCCESSFULLY COMPETE FOR
FUNDING FROM THE COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OPERATED BY CAL FIRE CAL- YES
AND OTHERS THIS IS A WIN WIN.
REGIONAL ENTITIES RECEIVE
SCARCE RESOURCES FOR PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT AND THE STATE GETS
A OF THOUGHTFUL AND STRATEGIC
SET OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
TAILORED TO THE SPECIFIC NEEDS
OF EACH REGION. AB NINE ENSURES
THE PROGRAM COVERS ALL REGIONS
THAT HAVE HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES AND EXPANDS THE
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE COMMUNITY
PREPAREDNESS WORK SUCH AS HOME
HARDENING IN THE CREATION OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. ON THE PHONE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- KAREN
BERGER WITH THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND
KAREN GAFFNEY WITH THE NORTH
COAST RESOURCE PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU A MODERATOR. CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR THE
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU
THEIR LINES ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR I AM KAREN
BERGER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
ARE TO EITHER A KEY COMPONENT
IN ADDRESSING THE STATE'S
WILDFIRE CRISIS. OUR UNIQUE
POSITIONING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PUBLIC
ENABLE US TO HAVE DIRECT
CONVERSATIONS WITH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC LANDOWNERS AND IMPLEMENT
EFFECTIVE LOCALLY APPROPRIATE
PROJECT REGARDING FOREST AND
WATERSHED HEALTH WHILE ALSO
MEETING THE HOMEOWNERS TO
PROVIDE KNOWLEDGE ON HOME
GARDENING. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES FACING OUR CITY THAT
HAVING THE CAPACITY TO PLAN AND
DESIGN GOOD PROJECT.
PARTICULARLY TAKING THE TIME TO
ENGAGE PARTNERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND OTHERS IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY TO CREATE A
PIPELINE OF GOOD PROJECT. AND
WE KNOW THE SAME CAPACITY
CHALLENGES EXIST FOR OUR
NONPROFIT LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
TRIBAL COLLEAGUE. WITHOUT GOOD
PROJECT DESIGNED IN
COLLABORATION OUR WORK IS LESS
EFFECTIVE SILOS AND REDUNDANT.
THAT IS WHY WE'RE IN SUCH
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE AND
THE REGIONAL POOREST EMPIRE
CAPACITY PROGRAM. BY FINANCIAL
AND TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
INCREASE CAPACITY AT THE LOCAL
AND REGIONAL SCALE TO DRIVE
COLLABORATION AND IDENTIFY PLAN
AND DEVELOP EFFECTIVE PROJECT
THE INCREASE WILDFIRE
RESILIENCY. IT'S REALLY HELPFUL
THAT ARE AT THAT FIFTY DOES NOT
FORCE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH TO HOW OUR REGION OF
THE FINE. OR WHO SERVES AS THE
HUB FOR THE REGION IT ALLOWS
EACH REGION TO ADDRESS ITS
UNIQUE CHALLENGES WITH ITS
UNIQUE PLAYERS. FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE THIS PROGRAM IS
EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE. BY RTT
MEMBERS ARE RECIPIENTS OF OUR
FFE FUND AT THE FUNDING. INLAND
EMPIRE AND SAN DIEGO ARE
TEDIOUS AND SERVICE THE
REGIONAL ENTITIES THAT ARE
DEVELOPING AND REGION AT THE
REGIONAL PLANS TO PRIORITIZE
THE PROJECTS IN THEIR AREA. IN
ADDITION MANY RCTS AND PA
ARCADY ARE SUB GRANTEES WORKING
TOGETHER WITH REGIONAL PARTNERS
SUCH AS THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
AND THE FEAR IN ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY TO HELP THOSE
CONSERVATIVE DEVELOP THEIR
REGIONAL PLAN. WE APPRECIATE
AND VALUE THE UNIQUE WORK. WERE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH WITH THE
SPENDING. THE RSS HAS THAT A
CRITICAL NEED IN THE FACE
APPROACH TO CREATING GREATER
WHILE BY OUR HIGHER RESILIENCY.
INVESTING IN PRODUCT
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT WE CAN
BUILD A PIPELINE OF ATTRACTIVE
PROJECT. THEY CAN THEN LEVERAGE
FUNDING AND SUPPORT FROM LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL SOURCES. RSS
FC'S REGION BY REGION APPROACH
AND FOCUS ON CAPACITY IN
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO WILDFIRE. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT AB NINE AND
ARE REALLY APPRECIATIVE I'VE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
THAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
KAREN GAFFNEY WITH THE NORTH
COAST RESEARCH PARTNERSHIP HERE
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE. FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS THE PARTNERSHIP
HAS BEEN LED BY SEVEN COUNTIES
AND REPRESENTATIVES REPUBLIC
THIRTY FOUR FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN THE
NINETEEN THOUSAND SQUARE MILE
NORTH COAST REGION OF
CALIFORNIA. THE NORTH COAST
REGION IS A CRITICAL SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SOME OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT BIODIVERSITY IN
THE STATE AND KEY GEOGRAPHY
PRESS CRAFTING CARBON. 12% OF
THE LAND AND CULTURE HAS. OVER
25% OF THE STATE'S CUTTERS OVER
THE LAST NINETY. INCLUDING
TRAGIC LOSS OF LIFE CLIMATE AND
HEALTH IMPACTS. HEALTHY FORESTS
ON THE NORTH COAST ACHIEVE
MULTIPLE BENEFITS FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE SAME WAY THAT
HEALTHY FORESTS IN THE SIERRA
NEVADA AND OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA DO. BUT AREN'T SEXY
PROGRAM IS SUPPORTING IT ON
PATREON PARTNERSHIPS AND
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THE RGD
DURABLE COLLABORATIVE A GROUP
OF RCTS FOR WORKING WITHIN THE
REGION. IN DEVELOPING REGIONAL
SCIENCE BASED ASSESSMENTS AND
PLANS THAT ALIGN STATE FEDERAL
TRIBAL AND LOCAL OBJECTIVES.
RESULTING IN AN ONGOING
PIPELINE OF HIGH PRIORITY
PROJECTS BUT YOU'RE READY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. AND A SET OF
REPORTING METRICS THAT DOCUMENT
THE STATE'S RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. OUR REGION
APPRECIATES. PROGRAM AND
PROJECT ON CAPACITY BUILDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EQUITY
COSTS UNDER A COLLABORATION AND
THE CREATION OF SHARED REGIONAL
PRIORITIES. AND WE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE HIGH STANDARDS
OF THE PROGRAM FOR BLINKING
PLANNING WITH ON THE GROUND.
OUTCOMES AND PROJECT
DOCUMENTATION. A NINE WHICH- AN
EX THE- OF COMPOUND THAT BEEN
BILL AND- ECONOMIC CHILD. AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY PER OF CALLING.
ALLOWING TO CAN TO WORK
TOGETHER A STRETCHER SLASH. TO
TRULY MOVE THE NEEDLE ON FOREST
AND COMMUNITY HEALTH. THANK YOU
TO ASSEMBLY WORK FRANTICALLY IN
THE PARKING LOT TO SHUT.
COPYRIGHT. I REQUEST THAT YOU
HIGH. THANK YOU WE ARE FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. MODERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN THE LIGHTS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEDUNJANIN
WAS OUT FOR A NEW STRATEGY
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FOREST FOUNDATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE OH
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE TELEPHONE TALENTS WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE AND WE
THINK IT'S ON THE NUMBER WHICH
POLICIES WORK WITHIN THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT SPACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AN ACTUAL GOAL LINE
OF SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I HAVEN'T BEEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXAVAR TO LINE UP FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MARK INSTRUMENT
BURKE WITH A WATERSHED RESEARCH
AND TRAINING CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO TO THE
LINE OF ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FOR THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
C. NINE ANY WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION. I
DON'T SEE ANY- I WANT TO OPEN
IT UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY SO MR WHAT
WOULD YOU BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT YES AND
THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
MENTION THAT SOONER. ARAMBULA
I'M WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE-
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T SIX AB NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD. MEMBERS
THREE OF US I RIVAS FIVE FLORA
FLORA HI CHAU CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN HI GARCIA. MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MURATSUCHI SAY ARE CHAU HI
THEY ARE TO AYE STONE STONE I
WOULD I WOULD I. NINE ZERO
EIGHT NINE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE AB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN. HI THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THIS.
THANK YOU BOTH. THIS COMMITTEE
IS MORE THAN FAMILIAR WITH THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THAT HAVE
LED TO THE CLOSURE RECYCLING
CENTERS OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
SO I'LL SPARE YOU RECOUNTING
THOSE DETAILS AS YOU KNOW THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO REDEMPTION
OPTIONS HAS BECOME PARTICULARLY
ACUTE IN RURAL AREAS AND THE
PANDEMIC HAS MADE THINGS EVEN
WORSE MUCH OF THE MODERN
RECYCLING MOVEMENT CAN TRACE
ITS ROOTS BACK TO HUMBOLDT
COUNTY AND THE CITY OF ARCADIA
IN MY DISTRICT FOR DECADES
LEADERS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
HAVE LED THE WAY. TRAGICALLY AS
IT STANDS TODAY IS EFFECTIVELY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR RESIDENTS IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY TO REDEEM THEIR
CRB CONTAINERS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THERE WERE ONLY THREE
REDEMPTION CENTERS THAT SERVE
THE FOUR THOUSAND SQUARE MILE
COUNTY. LIKE MANY BUSINESS.
OWNERS AND BUSINESSES ACROSS
THE STATE THOSE REDEMPTION
CENTERS WERE FORCED TO CLOSE
DURING THE MANDATORY SHUT DOWN
ORDER. WHEN THE SHUTDOWN ORDER
WAS LIFTED ONLY ONE REDEMPTION
CENTER REMAIN TO SERVE BECAUSE
CONSUMERS IN THE COUNTY. AND
THE PENT UP DEMAND WAS TRULY
AMAZING. THE LINES AND CROWDS
OF FORM CAUSE TRAFFIC JAMS IT
BACKED UP ON THE HIGHWAY
CREATED A PUBLIC SAFETY
SITUATION SO SEVERE THAT COUNTY
OFFICIALS WERE FORCED TO CLOSE
THE CENTER. AS A RESULT THERE
ARE NOW ZERO REDEMPTION CENTERS
IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY. TODAY A
RESIDENT OF ARCADIA. WHO WANTS
TO REDEEM THEIR CRB CONTAINERS
WOULD HAVE TO DRIVE EITHER ONE.
AND A HALF HOURS EACH WAY TO
CRESCENT CITY AND THAT'S
ASSUMING THE HIGHWAYS OPEN
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN CLOSED A LOT
THIS YEAR. OR TWO AND A HALF
HOURS EACH WAY. TO WILLITS IN
THE SOUTH. WE HAVE WORKED WITH
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY
A HANDFUL OF SMALL CHANGES THAT
WOULD ALLOW RECYCLING CENTERS
TO RE OPEN. IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
AS A RESULT THE BILL DOES FOUR
THINGS. THAT AUTHORIZES CALVET
RECYCLE TO ALLOW CERTIFIED
RECYCLING CENTERS OPERATE ON AN
ALTERNATIVE SCHEDULE IF IT IS
BEST SERVES THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY. AND THE GOALS OF THE
BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM. NUMBER TWO
IT REQUIRES CAL RECYCLE TO
DEVELOP A PROCESS THAT WOULD
ALLOW RECYCLING CENTERS TO
APPLY FOR AUTHORIZATION TO
OPERATE BY APPOINTMENT. THREE
IT EXEMPTS DEALERS DELIVERING
EMPTY BEVERAGE CONTAINERS TO A
RECYCLING CENTER PROCESSOR FROM
THE DAILY LOAD LIMITS. AND FOR
IT AUTHORIZES BAG DROP
RECYCLING CENTERS AND SETS A
THREE DAY STANDARD FOR PAYMENT
OF C. R. V. THESE MODEST
CHANGES WILL BY NO MEANS SOLVE
ALL THE PROBLEMS FACING THE
BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM. THESE DAYS
BUT THE ADDRESS A CRISIS IN MY
DISTRICT AND HOPEFULLY THEY
WILL HELP OTHER COMMUNITIES
STRUGGLING WITH ACCESS TO
REDEMPTION CENTERS TO. ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC. THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I
SUPPORT. THE RIGHT VOTE. THANK
YOU WE ARE READY FOR THE
WITNESS MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE. THANK YOU
I DO NOT SEE HAD A FINE ON BUT
IF HE IS ON YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THREE YEAR OLD WILL
OPEN YOUR LINE. ONE AND ZERO.
MISTER KENNEDY IS ON. I'M SORRY
I DID NOT SEE HIS LINE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THEN WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO ON A SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS BONNIE BUT- IF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF ONE OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC- STAR
AND THAT THE OPPORTUNITY
EARLIER WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN WE
CAN'T IN THE COMMON SENSE AFTER
FOR BY POWER CYCLE THE
FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED TO TAILOR
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAMS TO MEET
LOCAL NEEDS INCREASE CONSUMER
ACCESS TO REDEMPTION
OPPORTUNITIES- AS MR WOODS SAID
WITH A CLOSER SO MANY CERTIFIED
RECYCLING CENTERS. THAT
CONVENIENT BEVERAGE CONTAINER
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES DON'T
EXIST IN MANY PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS WE HAVE THREE COUNTIES
WITH NO RECYCLING CENTERS SEVEN
WITH A SINGLE RECYCLING CENTER
AND SIX THAT HAVE ONLY TWO
RECYCLING CENTERS. SO WITHOUT
CONVENIENT REDEMPTION
OPPORTUNITIES THE PROGRAM CAN
EASILY BECOME A REGRESSIVE TAX
WE THINK THIS BILL GOES A LONG
WAY TO PROVIDING SOME
COMMONSENSE RELIEF AS I SAID
AND MAKING IT EASIER FOR
CONSUMERS TO GET THEIR CRP
PAYMENTS BACK THANK YOU MR WOOD
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU MEXICO
TO LINE OF ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JEFF DONLEVY WITH
MINGS RECYCLING AND MING'S
RESOURCES IN HAYWARD- WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY LIKE TO SEE IT AS AN
URGENCY BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT OR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU- ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. I DON'T SEE
ANY OF ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. CAN'T
THERE ARE NONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I. PHONE. THANK YOU I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A MOTION YES FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
SEVEN AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD. MEMBERS
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA I
CHAU. CHAU HI FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI SO YOUR TOTAL HI
THEY ARE T<c.cyan> STONE. STONE I</c>
WOULD FIVE WOOD HI TEN ZERO.
TEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BENNETT. IS HE IN THE ROOM.
ONLY THAT MAX. AS OF K. THANKS
GO AHEAD AND START WITH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SURE I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL OF THE
AMENDMENTS FOUND IN THE
KNOWLEDGE SURCHARGE TECHNICAL
AND NON SUBJECT OF AND WE
CERTAINLY ACCEPT ALL OF. THE
AMENDMENTS. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX CALIFORNIA ESTABLISHED A
COASTAL CONSERVANCY A NON
REGULATORY AGENCY TO PROTECT
AND IMPROVE NATURAL LANDS. AND
WATERWAYS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX BEACH EROSION AUTHORITY FOR
CLEAN OCEANS AND NOURISHMENT.
REFERRED TO AS BEACON WAS
ESTABLISHED AS A JOINT POWERS
AGENCY TO PROVIDE SIMILAR
SERVICES IN THE SOUTH CENTRAL
COAST. BEACON CONDUCTS COASTAL
ROAD AND STUDIES AND
RESTORATION PROJECTS WITHIN ITS
JURISDICTION IN COORDINATION
WITH PARKS PLANNING AND PUBLIC
WORKS DEPARTMENTS OF ITS MEMBER
AGENCIES. TO ADDRESS SEA LEVEL
RISE AND COASTAL EROSION.
BEACON WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
THE CITY OF VENTURA IN THE
FAIRGROUNDS IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE SURFERS POINT PROJECT TO
RESTORE THE COASTLINE. BETWEEN
THE VENTURA PIER AND THE
VENTURA RIVER ESTUARY. IT HAS
SERVED AS A NATIONAL MODEL. IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT BEACON
RELEASED THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
OVERVIEW OF THE SANTA BARBARA
TURK COAST CREATED TO DATE. AND
THEIR PROGRAMMATIC
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT P.
E. I. R. SERVES AS THEIR
RESILIENCY ROAD. TO POINT
CONCEPTION TO POINT A GROUP. AB
EIGHT TWENTY SIX PROMOTES THE
STATE'S EFFORTS IN BOTH
RESILIENCY ADOPTION PLANNING BY
ESTABLISHING BEACON AS A
PROGRAM WITHIN THE STATE.
COASTAL CONSERVANCY. IT WOULD
ALLOW BEACON TO RECEIVE FUNDING
FROM BOND AND GRANT FUNDS AND
FURTHER ENSURE THAT THEIR WORK
ON THE CENTRAL COAST CONTINUES.
THIS BILL IS AUTHORED BY A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF SUPPORT OF-
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE CENTRAL
COAST REGION. WHOSE DISTRICTS
ARE SERVED BY BEACON. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I APPRECIATE
THAT WE HAVE TESTIMONY COMING
FROM SANTA BARBARA SUPERVISOR
GREG HART. AND FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST-
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE COUNTY
OF VENTURA ELIZABETH ESPINOSA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE'RE READY FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND I'D
LIKE TO REMIND THE WITNESSES
THAT YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU THEIR LINE OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT I'M
GREG HART A MEMBER OF THE SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND CHAIR OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS A BEACON TO
BEACH EROSION AUTHORITY FOR
CLEAN OCEANS IN NURSING AT THE
BEACON ROAD IN THE FORTY FOR
CLEAN OCEANS AND NOURISHMENT IS
IT CALIFORNIA JOINT POWERS
AGENCY ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX. THE COLLABORATIVE
WE ADDRESS COASTAL EROSION
BEACH NOURISHMENT AND CLEAN
OCEANS THROUGHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST FROM
POINT CONCEPTION THE POINT OF
VIEW THE MEMBER AGENCIES A
BEACON INCLUDE THE COUNTY TO
SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA AS
WELL AS THE COASTAL CITIES OF
SANTA BARBARA GOLETA
CARPINTERIA VENTURA OXNARD AND
PORT HUENEME THE- COASTAL
SEDIMENT MANAGEMENT A CRITICAL
COMPONENT IN SEA LEVEL RISE
ADAPTATION IN CALIFORNIA IS
BEAT BUILT ON REGIONAL SEGMENT
MANAGEMENT. REGIONAL SENTIMENT
MANAGEMENT IS MANAGED IN THE
STATE BY VARIOUS REGIONAL
AGENCIES AND COLLABORATIVE
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SEDIMENT MANAGEMENT WORK GROUP
THAT ALSO INCLUDES SPEAK IT
BECOMES MORE THAN A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILE COASTLINE COVERING
SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTY IS THE STATE'S LARGEST
COASTAL LIBERALS STYLE. SANTA
BARBARA LITERAL SELL A LITTLE
TELLS THE DISTINCT AREA THE
COAST OR SAND ENTERS THE OCEAN
FLOWS DOWN THE COAST. AND THEN
IS REMOVED FROM THE SYSTEM.
EIGHT TO REACH SERVICE MANAGER
INCLUDE AND- FUNDING FOR
REGIONAL SEVEN MANAGEMENT
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION IS
INADEQUATE EPISODIC IN
INSUFFICIENT TO MEET THE
INCREASING NEED. WE CANNOT
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT REGIONAL
SETTLEMENT MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
WITH ONLY LOCAL RESOURCES WE
NEED A STRONGER PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TO ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
SERIOUS NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
COASTAL ACCESS AND LOSS OF
COASTAL HABITAT THAT IS
OCCURRING FROM SEA LEVEL RISE.
AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX WOULD
POTENTIALLY PROVIDE STRONGER
STATE SUPPORT TO REGIONAL
SETTLEMENT MANAGEMENT PLANNING
AND FUNDING SUPPORT. WITHIN THE
SANTA BARBARA LITERAL CELL THE
STATE'S LARGEST COASTAL
LIBERALS UP THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
PROCEED MADAM CHAIR THIS IS A
LIST THAT THAT YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
ELIZABETH HAS BEEN- SOME BEHALF
OF THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT TO SIX. AS DESCRIBED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT AND
IN THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS THIS
MEASURE WOULD ESTABLISH THE
LONG STANDING BEACON PROGRAM AS
A PROGRAM UNDER THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY. THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT WOULD BUILD ON THE
GREAT SUCCESSES ACHIEVED BY THE
THIRTY FIVE YEARJOINT EFFORT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTY
SANTA BARBARA. AND MANY OF OUR
CITIES ALONG THE SOUTH CENTRAL
COAST. ESTABLISHING BEACON AS A
PROGRAM UNDER THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY WILL ENHANCE ACCESS
TO GRANT OPPORTUNITIES AND
PROMOTE GREATER COMMUNICATION
AND COORDINATION AMONG AND
BETWEEN PARTICIPATING AGENCIES
AND THE STATE. INTERNEES
BENEFITS WOULD HELP YOU CAN
DEVOTE MORE OPEN SPACE AND
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES. FURTHER
ENHANCE CONSERVATION EFFORTS
AND ADVANCEHABITAT RESTORATION
AND PRESERVATION PROJECTS ALL
OF WHICH ARE IMPORTANT POLICY
OBJECTIVES FOR THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA. FOR THESE REASONS THE
COUNTY OF VENTURA IS PLEASED TO
STAND WITH OUR PARTNER AGENCIES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT AB EIGHT TO SIX
WE THANK HIM FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ENHANCE
OPPORTUNITIES FURTHERING THE
GOALS OF THE BEACON PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE ARE
READY FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES. THANK YOU IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
AB EIGHT TO SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
IT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. MMI
RAIDER WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY
ANY WITNESSES THAT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. I DON'T SEE
ANY ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THERE ARE
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BY.
THE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. WE HAVE. MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I'M NOT SURE IF
I HAVE A MOTION. THANK YOU SO
MOTION- IS FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY I'M SECRETARY K.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I TO MATE
AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT MEMBERS
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORIDA. CHAU
CHOW I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I'D
GARCIA. MATHIS MATHIS NO
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
THEY ARE CHAU SAY OUR JOURNAL
STONE. STONE I WOULD WOOD I.
SIX TWO. SIX TO THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE AB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
WHICH PROPOSES THE DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF A
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT THAT WILL
ENCOURAGE ROBUST ECOLOGICALLY
AND REGIONALLYAPPROPRIATE
INVESTMENTS IN FIRE RESILIENCE
ANDRISK MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
THAT WILL MAKE. THAT WILL BE A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF OUR
STATE'S FIRE RISK REDUCTION
STRATEGY MOVING FORWARD. I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THANKS COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE CALIFORNIA'S
FIRE REGIMES ARE CHANGING DUE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND DROUGHT
STRESSORS. THE OF THESE FIRE
THREATS IMPACTS OUR COMMUNITIES
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT. AND OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
WATER QUALITY SPECIAL HABITATS
IN OUR PUBLIC LANDS. FIRES ARE
BECOMING MORE SEVERE AND
DESTRUCTIVE AS WE ALL KNOW.
FIVE OF THE TOP TWENTY LARGEST
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES OCCURRED
IN TWENTY TWENTY. THERE WERE
OVER NINETY FOUR HUNDRED FIRES
LAST YEAR. EARNING FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION ACRES AND THAT
SADLY- WE HAVE THE LOSS OF FOR
THIRTY THREE LIVES LAST YEAR
THE FIRES INCLUDED THE LARGEST
FIRE ON RECORD THE AUGUST
COMPLEX FIRE. INCREASE FUNDING
HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO HELP
ECOLOGICALLY MANAGE OUR FORCE
FOR AWHILE FOR RESILIENCE AND
FORCED HEALTH. WHICH IS A
CRITICAL ACCIDENT MUST CONTINUE
AT A GREATER PACE AND SCALE.
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE THREATS OF
WILDFIRES IMPACTING COMMUNITIES
AND NON FORESTED HABITATS. MUCH
OF THE STATE'S INVESTMENT IS
FOCUSED ON WILDFIRE RESPONSE
AND SUPPRESSION WHICH WE
UNDERSTAND UGH THAT TO NEEDS TO
BE IN FACT THAT LAST YEAR
WILDFIRE SUPPRESSION RESPONSE.
A WIND UP COSTING ABOUT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS. WHILE WILL
ALWAYS LIKELY HAVE TO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NEED FOR THAT
SUPPRESSION A RESPONSE WE NEED
TO MAKE GREATER INVESTMENTS IN
RISK REDUCTION AND RESILIENCE
STRATEGIES AND ACTIVITIES THAT
CAN HELP REDUCE THE
CATASTROPHIC IMPACTS AND OWNERS
COST OF WILDFIRES THAT WAS WHAT
YESTERDAY SAYS SIGNING OF THE-
OF A BUDGET ACTION THAT THE
ASSEMBLY SIGNED ON TO ON MONDAY
WAS ALL ABOUT- WE'RE PROVIDING
FUNDING. TO UGH UGH ACHIEVE OUR
PREVENTION GOALS. THE GOAL OF
AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE IS TO
ENCOURAGE ROBUST AND REGIONALLY
AND ECOLOGICALLY APPROPRIATE
INVESTMENTS IN FIRE RESILIENCE
AND RISK MITIGATION PROJECTS
THAT WILL IMPROVE THE STATE'S
OVER ALL WILDFIRE RESPONSE
IMPROVE FOREST HEALTH PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES AND HELP
JUMPSTART ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
THE FOREST SECTOR. THE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT PROPOSED BY A B.
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE WILL IDENTIFY
AND DEFINE APPLICABLE REGIONS
OF THE STATE ACCOUNTING FOR AND
DISTINGUISHING HABITAT
CHARACTERISTICS IN ORDER TO
IDENTIFY EFFECTIVE WILDFIRE
RISK REDUCTION ACTIVITIES. THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS OF THE BILL BECAUSE IT
RECOGNIZES THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF
OUR STATE AND WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT EACH REGION IN THE STATE
IS BEING TREATED APPROPRIATELY.
THERE BOY THEREBY AVOIDING A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT WILL ALSO
DESCRIBE REGIONAL STRATEGIES
ACTIVITIES AND TECHNIQUES TO
SUPPORT FIRE RISK REDUCTION AND
COMMUNITY PROTECTION AND
FINALLY. THE DOCUMENT WILL BE
DEVELOPED THROUGH A PUBLIC
PROCESS AND IN COORDINATION
WITH OUR EXPERT PUBLIC AGENCIES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT IT
REFLECTS REGIONAL STAKEHOLDER
INPUT AND THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE DOCUMENT
ARE REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR
REGIONAL NEEDS. THE FINAL PIECE
IS AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT AND
ENSURES THAT THE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT IS NOT DEVELOP
UNILATERALLY AND UTILIZES AND
PROMOTES EXISTING REGIONAL
EXPERTISE. AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
ADVANCES MANY OF THE GOALS AND
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN
THAT WITH WAS RELEASED EARLIER
THIS YEAR BY THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE WITH
PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO
INNOVATIVE AND EFFICIENT
SOLUTIONS THAT TACKLE HABITAT
SPECIFIC NEEDS. AB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE IS INTENDED TO COMPLEMENT
OTHER REGIONAL APPROACH AS PUT
FORWARD BY MY COLLEAGUES THIS
YEAR AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH THEM TO
SUPPORT THE ENTIRETY OF OUR
DIVERSE STATE. THE BILL WRAPPED
AROUND EXISTING WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RISK REDUCTION
PROGRAMS TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE COMPLEXITY OF COMMUNITY
SAFETY NEEDS TYPES OF WILDFIRE
CONDITIONS. AND THE DIVERSITY
OF HABITAT TYPES THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY WILDFIRE. I AM
PLEASED TO HAVE FOUGHT WITH ME.
MICHAEL WELL- ON THE PHONE
MICHAEL O'CONNELL PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE IRVINE RANCH
CONSERVANCY AND BRITNEY FANTASY
GOVERNMENT COMMUNITY AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR OF THE SIERRA BUSINESS
COUNCIL TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE. THANK
YOU AND WE'RE READY FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES EACH WILL START
WITH MICHAEL O'CONNELL. GOOD
MORNING JERRY THIS AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- I MICHAEL
O'CONNELL PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
IRVINE RANCH CONSERVANCY
LOCATED IN ORANGE COUNTY WE'RE
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION AND WE
MANAGE THIRTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
FIRE PRONE URBAN WILDLAND IN
CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH PUBLIC
LAND OWNERS. THE MOST IMPORTANT
POINT I WANT TO MAKE TODAY IS
THAT WILDFIRES DIFFERENT UP AND
DOWN THE STATE BUT WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY ADDRESSED FIRE
RISK FROM AN APPROACH FOCUSED
MOSTLY ON FUELS AND
SUPPRESSION. THERE ARE IN FACT
TWO MAJOR TYPES OF WILDFIRE
THAT REQUIRE VERY DIFFERENT
SOLUTIONS THE FIRST FIELD
DOMINATED FIRE IS MORE
CONVENTIONAL AND REQUIRES FUEL
REDUCTION IN TREATMENT BUT THE
WILD LAND IN COASTAL SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE THE SECOND TYPE
WHICH IS NGUYEN DOMINATED FIRE.
OUR RISK IS DUE TO THE
COMBINATION OF HIGH WINDS AND
IGNITIONS AND IS NEARLY
INDEPENDENT OF FUELS WE NEED TO
BETTER INTEGRATE THIS
UNCONVENTIONAL TYPE OF WILDFIRE
INTO STATE RESPONSE IN ORDER TO
REDUCE THE RISK TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WILDLANDS WE
NEED RESOURCES DIRECTED TO THE
APPROPRIATE SOLUTIONS IN EACH
REGION. THE THREAT OF WIND
DOMINATED FIRES ARE NOT EVER
GOING TO BE REDUCED BY
RESTORING FORESTS ARE THINNING
OUT DEAD WOOD IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE FORCE WE
HAVE TROUBLE AND- THIS IS THE
MOMENT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT A BROADER MORE NUANCED
MORE REGIONALLY APPROPRIATE
APPROACH. BASED ON HOW FIRE
ACTUALLY WORKS UP AND DOWNTHE
STATE. THE INTENT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOMS BILL FOR THE
STATE TO COMPILE COORDINATE AND
INVEST IN SOLUTIONS THAT WORK
FOR EACH REGION. AND FOR
DIFFERENT FIRE REGIMES AND
HABITAT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THERE'S ALSO GREAT POTENTIAL
FOR INTEGRATION AND SYNERGY
WITH THE REGIONAL EFFORTS
SUPPORTED BY THE REGIONAL
FORCED EMPIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM.
I APPRECIATE THE APPROACH THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM IS
PROPOSING AND THANK HIM FOR HIS
WORK ON A TWELVE FIFTY FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO VOTE ON BY TODAY ON AB
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PRETTY BAD IF YOU IF
YOU'RE A BUSINESS COUNCIL AS
NOTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
SCALE CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE
CREDIT THAT IS MAPPED IN
MEETING THAT CHALLENGE REQUIRED
BOTH IMMEDIATE ACTION AND
EFFICIENT STRATEGIC PLANNING
WHICH STARTS WITH ADDRESSING
THE NEW WANTED THE UNIQUE
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS WITHIN
EACH REGION OF THE STATE.
YOU'RE A BUSINESS COUNCIL THE
PURPLE LINE ORGANIZATION BASED
IN TRUCKEE AND SERVING THE
SIERRA NEVADA REGION. WE'VE
SEEN FIRSTHAND AS SO MANY OF US
HAVE THE IMPACT CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE TORE COMMUNITIES
ECONOMY AND ENVIRONMENT. AND
WHILE THE IMPORTANCE OF
EMPOWERING REGIONAL RESILIENCE
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION.
MUCH OF OUR WORK FOCUSES ON THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN RURAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
CLIMATE RESILIENT. INTERFERE
INCREASE IN OUR FOURTH HEALTH
NOT ONLY DECREASES OUR WILDIRE
RISK IT FRANKLIN'S ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR
TOURISM AND RESOURCE BASED
ECONOMY. THESE OPPORTUNITIES
ARE FOUND IN ECOLOGICALLY BASED
STANDING AND BIOENERGY IN
CONCERT IN LOCALLY MANAGED
RECREATION AREAS IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING FOR
PRESCRIBED FIRECREWS ARE VERY.
ADVANCED WHEN ENGINEERING AND
MARK. AT THE IT'S PARTICULARLY
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWELVE FIVE
BECAUSE THE PROMOTE THE
IMPORTANCE OF REGIONAL PLANNING
AND LOCAL INPUT. AB CALL FIFTY
FIVE NOT ONLY RECOGNIZES THAT
ONE THAT ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT
ALL IT RECOGNIZES THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS LOCAL EXPERTS ON
THE GROUND WHO KNOW WHAT IT'S
FOR THEIR REGION. BY ELEVATING
THAT LOCAL EXPERTISE AND
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FUNDING WE CAN ENSURE THAT
EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON WILDFIRE
MITIGATION AND THE MEANINGFUL
INVESTMENT. BEFORE CLEAR
DRASTICALLY INCREASING THE
SECTOR'S WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. AB CALL
THIRTY FIVE WILL TAKE IMPORTANT
STEPS IN EXPLORING THE CURRENT
LIMITATION FOR THE STATE COURT
COURT AND IDENTIFYING. DID WE
DID GET DISCONNECTED FROM. THE
AT&T LINE. OKAY I'M SORRY CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES. YES PLEASE
CONTINUE OUT. THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AS WELL AS THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
FOCUS EFFORTS INCREASE
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE BUT- THANK
YOU. I'M NEXT WILL MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE
LINES PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION. AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. GIVE YOUR AT THE
PORTER OPPOSITION. OF AB ONE
TWO TWELVE FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. FOR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FIFTY DANIEL LYNCH
EXPECTING THE POOR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS.
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION AND
THE URBAN CORE AND THE INLAND
EMPIRE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EXTROVERTED A LINE OF- ONE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAN DELFINO REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANTS
DESTRUCTIVE VIçT IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
UP OF. ONE SEVENTEEN. ONE
MOMENT ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS NATALIE
NAMBA BEHALF OF MAKING REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT SUPPORT AND
COMMENDED DIVISION AS DETAILED
IN OUR LETTER. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO MORE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. THERE ARE
NONE I'M QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE QUESTIONS OKAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER C. R. TIENEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT THANK YOU.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD AND- BECAUSE I
THINK EVERYBODY HAS THAT THE
WILDFIRE SITUATIONS GOT
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO. ATTENTION
AND- AND WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
SCRAMBLE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT. SO I'M A FIRE GUY. TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT OKAY EXACTLY WHAT
IS THE HABITAT SPECIFIC FIRE
RISK REDUCTION IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DECIDE WHAT GETS
CLEARED CANNOT GETS CLEARED
BASED ON. HABITAT
CHARACTERISTICS OF AN AREA. OR
NEED BECAUSE YEAH THAT'S FOR ME
IT'S A LITTLE BIT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CLEAR AN
AREA BECAUSE IT HAS SOME
HABITAT. WELL IT'S BOTH IT'S
TAKING- THE ECOSYSTEM INTO
CONSIDERATION AND ALSO- THAT
THE TERRAIN AND THE- YOU KNOW
IN THE PROPER SITUATION FUELS-
AS YOU HEARD- AS I'VE I'M SURE
YOU KNOW. OF DIFFERENT AREAS OF
THE STATE HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS
SO BOB HOME HARDENING FOR
EXAMPLE- OF MAY BE- AND
APPROPRIATE- RESPONSE IN ONE
AREA OF THE STATE AND THAT NOT
SO MUCH IN ANOTHER. RIGHT THANK
YOU BY THIS I THINK IS
ACTUALLY. IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE- YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
TERRAIN ITSELF NOT THE OTHER
ASPECTS. IN DECIDING AND I CAN
USE OUR OUR COMMUNITY AS AN
EXAMPLE WE ALMOST BURNED P THE
WHOLE NEIGHBORHOOD. BECAUSE WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO- IN FRENCH ON
THE AREA THAT IS HABITAT. AND
THAT HABITAT- BURNED UP ALONG
WITH EVERYTHING ELSE AROUND IT.
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CLEAR THAT AREA. SO THAT WE
WOULD SAVE THE REST OF THE
HABITAT IT'S THERE IT ALMOST
SOUNDS LIKE THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE IMPEDIMENTS TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO BEFORE WELL IT IT
SHOULDN'T BE AN IMPEDIMENT TO
ANYTHING BECAUSE WHAT THE BILL
IS INTENDED TO DO IS SET UP- A
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING. IF THE
BILL ITSELF DOES NOT DETERMINE
WHICH AREA- AND WHICH
METHODOLOGIES CORRECTED ANY
PARTICULAR PLACE AT THAT
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING. IF
THAT BECOMES. A KIND OF CATCH
POINT AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET ACCOMPLISHED THE BILL
SCHACK PRECIADO APPRECIATE YOUR
BILL I DO- THANK YOU AND THAT
IS THE TROUBLE WITH THAT A
LITTLE BIT AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THE BILL IS STILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS WILL BE HAPPY TO TALK
TO YOU AND- SEE IF THEY'RE
IMPROVEMENTS- THAT CAN BE MADE
THAT ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS.
RIGHT I'D BE GLAD TO TALK TO
YOU OFF. OUTSIDE OF THIS AND-
AND HELP WORK ON SOME OF THESE-
I'VE NOT YET TO BE CONSULTED ON
ANY OF THESE BILLS. BY TODD
WELCOME THAT WILL MAKE A POINT
OF- ENGAGING WITH YOU IN YOUR
OWN WORK THANK YOU. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND I DO PLAN TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT- I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT. IT'S TAKING A
VERY DIFFERENT APPROACH TO WHAT
I'M- THAN THAN WHAT I'M DOING
IN A BILL THAT JUST PASSED IN
THIS COMMITTEE. I GUESS WHAT
CONCERNS ME IS THAT. MY
PERCEPTION OF THIS IS THAT THIS
IS KIND OF A TOP DOWN APPROACH.
CALIFORNICA READS THE DOCUMENT
AND THEN ALL THE REGION'S KINDA
DO THEIR WORK OUT BEHIND THE
SCENES. THAT KIND OF NEGATES
THE- THE GOOD WORK IS BEING
DONE IN MY DISTRICT BY GROUPS
LIKE NORTH COAST RESOURCE
PARTNERSHIP. AND OTHERS- AND
WHAT THEY REALLY NEED THEIR OF
THEIR THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND
THEY KNOW THEIR TERRAIN THEY
KNOW THE REGION'S WHAT THEY
NEED IS THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
TO GET TROUGH A PROCESS TO
QUALIFY FOR GRANTS. FROM CAL
FIRE AND CALIO WAS SENT OUT
CARILLO YES AND OTHERS. SO WE'D
REALLY LIKE. WHAT I'D REALLY
LIKE TO SEE IS THAT CALVET
MAYBE CALIFORNIA. CREATES A
DOCUMENT BASED UPON. THE WORK
IS BEING DONE ON THE GROUND NOT
JUST TAKING STAKEHOLDER INPUT.
THAT'S A VERY DIFFERENT PROCESS
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S SOME
PRIDE TO SOME FOLKS THAT ARE
DOING REALLY REALLY GOOD WORK.
THAT ARE GONNA BE LIKE WAIT A
SECOND WE'RE ALREADY DOING
THIS. WHAT READ BEING TOLD FROM
A TOP DOWN. WAY THAT THIS IS
THAT THIS IS THE WAY IT'S GOING
TO BE. SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW IF THAT'S THEY MIGHT
IF I MISS PERCEIVING WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE I. AND
I WANT TO WORK WITH YOU BECAUSE
AND I APPRECIATE EVERYTHING YOU
DID ON THAT WHILE FAR PACKAGE
FOR US AND- IT MEANS A LOT.
IT'S A VERY IN MY MIND IS A
VERY DIFFERENT APPROACH THAN
WHAT. WHAT I'M LOOKING AT NIGHT
COMPLETELY RECOGNIZE THAT
CHAPARRAL AND SOME OF THE OTHER
HABITATS IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
STATES. ARE VERY VERY DIFFERENT
AND THE REGIONAL INPUT IS
CRITICAL TO THAT. BUT I'M NOT
SURE THAT A TOP DOWN DOCUMENTS-
WITH THAT WITH THE WITH CAL
FIRE WHO'S ALREADY STRETCHED
BEYOND THEIR LIMITS- ENDS IN
FIRE SUPPRESSION YEAR AFTER
YEAR. IS THE RIGHT APPROACH TO
DO THAT. NOT ALSO JUST WANT TO
POINT ONE THING. WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE HERE IN YOUR
WITNESS AND TALKING ABOUT
NGUYEN DOMINATED FIRE- YES. YOU
GOT HE LOOK AT MY DISTRICT I'M
SORRY WE'VE HAD THREE OF THE
TOP FIVE FIVE LARGEST FIRES IN
THE HISTORY OF THE STATE
INCLUDING THE LARGEST AND TWO
OF THOSE TOP FIVE TOP BUYERS
WERE LAST YEAR. AND WIND
DOMINATED THOSE FIRES THE FUEL
SOURCES WERE DIFFERENT BUT YOU
CAN'T TELL ME THAT NGUYEN DID
NOT DOMINATE THOSE FIRES AND SO
I JUST. POINT THAT OUT- AS
SOMEONE WHO EXPERIENCED THAT
FIRSTHAND I THINK YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN- I AND I THINK- THE-
OF THE POINT TO THE WITNESS WAS
TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT-
DIFFERENT REGIONS DIFFERENT
FUEL SOURCES- ARE PREVALENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE
NEED TO TAKE EACH OF THOSE INTO
CONSIDERATION IT'S NOT TO THE-
EXCLUSION. OF THE OF A
CIRCUMSTANCES OF FIRES FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE NORTH COAST AND-
AND YOUR AREA OR IN THE SIERRAS
WHERE ARE OTHER WITNESS SPOKE
FROM- THESE ARE ALL DIFFERENT
AND ALL REQUIRE- ATTENTION SOME
MORE SO THAN OTHERS BUT-
CERTAINLY- A DIFFERENT
APPROACHES. COME ON ON YOUR
OTHER POINT- THIS IS INTENDED
TO BE AN INCLUSIVE AND
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS AND SO-
AS I OFFER TO OUR- A COLLEAGUE-
I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
WE SEE THESE BILLS YOUR BILLS-
AND OTHERS AS COMPATIBLE WITH
US WE WANT TO MAKE THEM- AS
COMPATIBLE. AS POSSIBLE SO I'LL
BE HAPPY TO WORK ON THAT WITH
YOU. I WOULD JUST I GUESS I
WOULD JUST SAY I WOULD HOPE
THAT I MEAN. THE FOLKS ON THE
GROUND WHETHER IT'S IN-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER C. ARCOS
DISTRICT ARE MATHIS OR OR
ANYBODY IN HERE THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT KNOW. THE REGION WELL
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT DEAL WITH
THIS ON ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
SO I STILL WONDER YOU KNOW
RASKIN CAL FIGHTER A TOP DOWN
CREATED DOCUMENT. AND I GUESS I
GUESS I GATHER I UNDERSTAND
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE INPUT.
BUT WHAT IT REALLY LIKE TO SEE
CAL FIRE DO. IS FACILITATE THE
PROJECTS ON THE GROUND
DEVELOPED BY THE EXPERTS IN
THOSE REGIONS RATHER THAN
CREATE TAKE ALL THIS INPUT
CREATED DOCUMENT AND THEN
DECIDE WHAT TO DO DO YOU SEE
WHERE I'M GOING WITH THAT. I
THINK SO AND LET ME TRY TO
REASSURE YOU AND AGAIN WE'LL
WORK TOGETHER ON THIS- MR
O'CONNELL- FROM THE IRVINE
RANCH CONSERVANCY- CAME TO MY
ATTENTION SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
OF THAT ISSUE- WHERE- HE HAS
LOCAL. A CONDITIONS THAT HIS
ADDRESS ON A LOCAL BASIS AND
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL AND- IN
DOING SO- AND HE LOOKS AT IT
FROM THE- PRECISE LENS THAT YOU
ARE. TALKING ABOUT AND THAT IS-
HOW DO WE BRING IN PEOPLE LIKE
HIMSELF WHO HAVE THAT LOCAL
EXPERTISE- AND- YOU DON'T KNOW
TH LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES. AND
MAKE SURE THAT TO- THE NEEDS
OF. LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
REGIONS ARE RESPECTED IN THE
PLANNING THAT WE DO THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. BUT SO I GUESS I
WOULD THEN ASK HIM YOU KNOW AND
MAYBE A QUESTION FOR HIM IS
WHAT DO YOU NEED THE MOST DO
YOU NEED THE RESOURCES TO DO
THESE PROJECTS. OR DO YOU NEED
A DOCUMENT THAT OUTLINES HOW
YOU DO THAT AND THAT'S AND
THAT'S WHERE THAT'S WHERE THAT.
IS PROBABLY STILL ON THE LINE
IF- WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS YEAH.
HIS PERSPECTIVE ON. HI I AM
STILL THE LINE I APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD AND I ACTUALLY-
THINK THAT AND I'VE SAID BEFORE
THAT I THINK. A BOTTOM UP
APPROACH IS REALLY THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY. MANAGE FIRE RISK.
GIVEN HOW DIVERSE THE FIRE RISK
PROFILES ARE IN VARIOUS PARTS
OF THE STATE. AND I TOTALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THE NATURE OF
THE FIRE ON THE NORTH COAST
ALONG THE COASTAL AREAS TO HELP
WIN DOMINATED FIRES BUT- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US THAT- WE
BE ABLE TO DEVELOP. OUR
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
OUR REGIONS. WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
SO EXCITED ABOUT THE ARE FSC
PROGRAM. AND THEN HAVE THAT
INTEGRATED. INTO THE STATES OF
THE STATE CAN SUPPORT THOSE-
THOSE PROCESSES AND SO I THINK.
I THINK THESE. TWO BILLS SEEM
TO BE COMING AT IT. THE SAME
THING FROM TWO DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS AND HOPEFULLY THEY
CAN MEET IN THE MIDDLE. IT
AFTER SHE THOUGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO I HAVE A QUESTION
OR A COMMENT ABOUT- SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY ON
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I BELIEVE
THAT IT'S THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY THAT IS CREATING THIS
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT I THINK
SOMEONE HAD. MANSION THAT WAS
CAL FIRE THERE UNDER CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING YES AND
NO CALIFORNIA IS UNDER THE
AGENCY THEY WORK TOGETHER WELL
THAT'S OKAY FOR SERVICE OKAY.
THEY USE PROP ARE- YES YOU TO
CREATE THE DOCUMENT OKAY. OKAY
THANK YOU I WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
DON'T HAVE A MOTION YET. WHO
BECAUSE OF SPACE OKAY. OKAY
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM NINE AB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA. CHAU CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I'D GARCIA GARCIA I
MATHIS. MCCARTY RIGHT TO G.
THEY ARE TOP NO. THERE ARE TWO
OH NO STONE. STONE I WOULD I
WOULD I. SIX ONE. SIX ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT. AND NEXT WE HAVE
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
BLOOM THANK YOU AGAIN- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AND I ARE CO
AUTHORING ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH WILL
PROVIDE AN URGENT SHORT TERM
FIX TO CALIFORNIA'S BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM.
LOW RETURNED CONSUMER FRIENDLY
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
INCREASE RECYCLING RATES AND
MODERNIZE PROGRAM INCENTIVES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES FOR LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY AND MARKET
PLACE RESILIENCY. WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GUIDANCE
AND EXPERTISE OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND PREPARE TO ACCEPT ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THE COMMITTEE IS OF COURSE WELL
AWARE OF THE- DETERIORATING
STATE OF THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM. A DROP IN
GLOBAL SCRAP PRICES HAS REDUCED
OUR RECYCLER VALUE BY NINETY
FIVE MILLION STATUTORY
CONSTRAINTS OF MADE PROGRAM
PAYMENTS SLOW AND INSUFFICIENT
TO COVER RECYCLING CENTER COSTS
DESPITE A FUND SURPLUS THAT
TOTALS MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP HAS RESULTED IN THE
CLOSURE OF NEARLY ONE THOUSAND
RECYCLING CENTERS IN THE PAST
FIVE YEARS MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THIRTY CITIES AND THREE ENTIRE
COUNTIES HAVE NO BUY BACK
RECYCLING CENTERS AT ALL. IN
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
WITH A POPULATION OF MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND CLOSE TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. WE JUST HAVE ONE
REMAINING RECYCLING CENTER.
CONSUMERS THAT RECYCLE FOR
CASH. AND THAT'S HOW THE VAST
MAJORITY OF BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
ARE STILL RETURNED HAVE
EXPERIENCED A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR PER MONTH DROP IN TOTAL
THE BAD NEWS. THERE IS HOPEFUL
NEWS AS WELL AND THAT IS THE
OPPORTUNITY. JUST SEVEN YEARS
AGO THE SAME PROGRAM HAD TWICE
AS MANY OPERATING CENTERS AND
WAS DELIVERING NEAR BEST IN THE
NATION RECYCLING RATES OF
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT. AND WITH
CALIFORNIA'S STRONGEST IN THE
NATION PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
FOR RECYCLED CONTENT. WE KNOW
THAT THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY MUST
BUY BACK COLLECTED GLASS AND
PLASTIC FOR RECYCLING RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE GET BACK
ON TRACK. SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FOUR WILL REINVEST SURPLUS
PROGRAM REVENUE TO PROVIDE
URGENT INCENTIVES TO SUPPORT
NEW AND STRUGGLING STRUGGLING.
RECYCLING CENTERS. IT'LL
PROVIDE START UP FUNDING IN THE
FORM OF FORGIVABLE LOANS TO
IMMEDIATELY BRING RECYCLING
CENTERS TO THE SIX HUNDRED MOST
NEEDY UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
AREAS. AND TARGETED INCREASE IN
PAYMENTS TO ENSURE SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR NEW AND EXISTING
RECYCLING CENTERS. AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY FORCE PROVISIONS RELY ON
PROGRAM DATA COST SURVEYS AND
DEPARTMENT RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO IMPLEMENT
LONG DISCUSSED SYSTEM UPDATES
AIMED AT MODERNIZING
SIMPLIFYING AND INCREASING
RESPONSIVENESS AND RESILIENCY.
TO CHANGING MATERIALS
TECHNOLOGIES AND MARKET
CONDITIONS. OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS MY STAFF AND I
HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE FULL SPECTRUM OF RECYCLING
PROGRAM STAKEHOLDERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT RECYCLERS CONSUMER
AND ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
MATERIAL COLLECTORS PROCESSORS
AND MANUFACTURES
REMANUFACTURES. AND EVERY TYPE
AND SIZE OF RETAILER FROM LARGE
SUPERMARKETS TO MOM AND POP
GROCERS. WE'VE HEARD MANY
THOUGHTFUL IDEAS FOR UPDATING
AND EVEN EXPANDING THE PROGRAM.
AND THERE MAY NOT BE A
CONSENSUS ON ALL OF THE IDEAS
THAT HAVE BEEN PRESENTED TO US
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
CONSENSUS ON THE CORE TENETS OF
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOR THIS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY. AND
THAT IS TO FOCUS ON FIXING
WHAT'S BROKEN. ENSURE THAT
EVERY COMMUNITY HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REDEEM AND AT
AND RECYCLE EMPTY CONTAINERS.
AND THERE'S GENERAL AGREEMENT
THAT. WE SHOULD MOVE WITH
URGENCY. WITH THE AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOUR UPDATES WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES THE FRAMEWORK AND THE
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITIES TO
RETURN CALIFORNIA'S CONTAINER
RECYCLING SYSTEM TO ITS FORMER
NATIONAL LEADERSHIP STATUS.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK ON THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS ARE MARK
MURRAY WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUP CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE AND SALLY HOW THàNH WITH
THE PLASTIC RECYCLING
CORPORATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU- WE'RE READY FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL GO
AHEAD AND START WITH MARK
MURRAY MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THIS IS MARK MURRAY WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE-
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A NUMBER
OF ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEMS WHOSE SOLUTIONS ARE
COMPLEX AND ELUSIVE RECYCLING
NOT NEED TO BE ONE OF THOSE
PROBLEMS CALIFORNIA HAS THE
EXPERIENCE AND THE RESOURCES TO
SUSTAIN IT 8285% RECYCLING WITH
THE CURRENT PROGRAM. IN FACT WE
WERE ACHIEVING THOSE RATES- AS
RECENTLY AS TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
FOR A DECADE BEFORE THAT- WE
CAN GET THERE AGAIN AND IF IN
IN AS FEW AS TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS BY BETTER DEPLOYING
EXISTING PROGRAM RESOURCES AND
MODERNIZING PROGRAM FEATURES-
YOU KNOW THE PROBLEM OF REDUCE
PAYMENTS REDUCE SCRAP VALUE
CLOSURE OF NEARLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND RECYCLING CENTERS AND
A 10215% DROP IN THE RECYCLING
RATE. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR
ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES WITH
PROVEN DATA DRIVEN SOLUTIONS
INCREASED PAYMENTS FOR ALL BY
BACK RECYCLING CENTERS BY 50%
LITERALLY PENNIES PER POUND FOR
GLASS AND PLASTIC THESE
INCREASES THE SPECIFIC
INCREASES ARE DERIVED DIRECTLY
FROM THE MOST RECENT DEPARTMENT
COST SURVEY START UP FUNDING TO
BRING RECYCLING CENTERS TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
RECYCLING RATES RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA OUR SUCCESSFUL 85%
OR BETTER IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE AT LEAST ONE RECYCLING
CENTER. PER TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE. TO GET
THERE WE NEED AS FEW AS FOUR
HUNDRED TO SIX HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL RECYCLING CENTERS.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR HELPS US
ET THERE. AND FINALLY THIS
MEASURE MODERNIZES PROGRAM
RULES AND INCREASES DEPARTMENT
FLEXIBILITY TO SITE AND SUPPORT
INNOVATIVE COLLECTION
OPPORTUNITIES AND DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY SECONDARY MATERIALS TO
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA WE
URGE AND I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS SALLY HOW TEN FROM
THE PLASTIC CORPORATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS HOLLY HOLM
THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF PRTC PRACTICALLY FIGHTING
CORPORATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
I'VE GOT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE MY SUPPORT
FOR A BI ONE FOUR FIVE FOUR.
PRCC WAS ESTABLISHED IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY AT TO SUPPORT
AB TWENTY TWENTY WE ARE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION AND I'M
PROUD TO SAY AN EARLY EXAMPLE
OF EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY. CURRENTLY P.
OFFICE HANDLED APPROXIMATELY
FORTY POLKA. OF THE MEDINA PT
PACKAGE CONTAINERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AT ITS INCEPTION
THERE WAS ONLY ONE NEW
RECLAIMING. AND NOW THEY'RE ALL
SIX AND PLC SHE BUT IN SUPPORT
FOR. THE BILL HAS PLAYED A-
PART IN THE SUCCESS THAT
RECYCLING. BY BUCKLEY AS WE
CALL IT GRADE EIGHT IS THE
MATERIAL OF CHOICE OF THOSE
RECLAIM THE- AND IT'S IMPAIR.
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE VALUE ALL
FIVE ACCENTED AND THE QUALITY
MATERIAL THEY PROVIDE. AND HOW
THE CALIFORNIA CIRCULAR
RECYCLING COMPANY IS BUILT
AROUND THAT GREAT. AND
ESPECIALLY WOULD. MANDATED
CONTENT ON THE HORIZON. THE
OFFICE GREATLY THE BOTTLE BILL
WRECKING IT SAYS THE SENATE
YEARS OLD AND NEED TO MODERNIZE
THE- THIS WILL SET IN MY NEED
UPDATE AND PRESS. IN TO READ
THE BOTTLE BILL. 82% HI WHICH
LIKE RATES AND MAKE IT MORE.
SECOND TO MAKE DEPARTMENTS. AB
ONE FULL CYCLE WILL STAY EVEN
THE INDUSTRY THROUGH TARGETED
FUNDING AND PROVIDE STARTUP
INCENTIVES FOR NEW CENTERS TO
OPEN UP AND I'M SAYS. AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES COUNTERCYCLICAL
DESIGNATE REGIONAL CONVENIENCE
AND SEVEN MULTIPLE UNDERSTANDS
AND- BASED ON THE COMMUNITY
NAMED. KNOWLEDGES AND MAY MAKE
SENSE IN SOME AREAS OF THE
STATE WHERE STILL CONVENIENT
FOR CONSUMERS TO MEDINA
CONTAINS. THIS BILL ALSO
AUTHORIZES CAL RECYCLED TOWARD
HANDLING FEES TO THE FIRST
OPERATOR TO OPEN IN A
CONVENIENCE AND THAT HAD BEEN
ON THE SENATE FOR MORE THAN SIX
MONTHS. THIS BILL BRINGS A
PROGRAM INTO THIS CENTURY BUT
WHAT THE RISING CERTIFIED
RECYCLING CENTERS TO PAY CLP TO
CONCEALMENT OF MATCHES- AND
NEKTONIC PAYMENTS. AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO CASH PAYMENTS.
FACILITATING PAID DROPOFF.
PROGRAMS SIMILAR TO THOSE IN
OREGON. I IT WILL PUSH OUT 50%
HIGHER PROFIT PAYMENTS- SET OF
TO SIGN CENTER FOR THE FIRST
FIVE GLASS CONTAINER. AND TWO
HUNDRED SAN PLUS CONTAINERS
COLLECTED EACH MONTH. THIS
PROVISION WILL PROVIDE
IMPORTANT SUPPORT TO THE
RECYCLING CENTERS THAT REMAIN
IN OPERATION AND NAY
ENCOURAGING SENTENCED. TELL
NATURE OF SCRAPPED BY
SHORTENING THE TIME FRAME FOR
MODIFYING PROCESSING PAID.
COULD COMMINGLED SUPPLY AND
ALUMINIUM CANS CONTAINERS MUST
BE THAT BASED ON THE TWO OR
THREE. INTO CONSUMER THINK NOT
MUCH REFER FROM TEN PRC'S
BELIEVES WE NEED TO CUT COMING
RIGHT TO BE T. ONE RATE TO FOUR
PT PRYOR CONTAINER AND ONE FOR
REGION PLASTIC BOTTLES OF THE.
THE AUSSIE SEE WHAT. ASK BUT
YOU ALSO. AB ONE FOUR FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NECK WILL
TO. I WHICH AN OFFICE WE HAVE
JAMIE COURT COND WATCH. HI
THANK FOR YOU NEED A- THE
RETENTION RATE CAL FIFTY SEVEN
WE ALL KNOW THE- THIRTEEN
HUNDRED CENTER HAD COLLAPSED
THE INPUT DON. THIS BILL MAKE
AGAINST OR LESS OF A NOT MORE.
AND IT DOES WHAT THIS CALL- HAS
NOW WHY DO PROGRAM FAILED LIST
IS THE- ITS- TO WEAR HAULERS
THAT RICH. AND IT- GRIP GROCERY
STORES OUT. THE BUSINESS OF
CONVENIENCE THE BILL READ DRAWS
BIGGER CA ON THAT. FEWER
GROCERY STORES WERE HAVE TO
BACK AND THESE WHEN WE HAVE A
COMMUNITY LIKE SOME MEMBER BLUE
WHERE THEY WERE NOT ONE
REDEMPTION CENTER. REDRAWN
CONVENIENCE TO BE BAY WORKS
GROCERY STORES TO- HAPPY TO
BACK FOR UP TO OF THE PAYMENT
DOES NOT MAKE THINGS MORE
CONVENIENT LESS- THEY'RE ALSO
BIG SUB TO HAULERS HERE WHICH
HAULERS. MORE THAN 50% OF THE
MONEY. IN THE PROGRAM ABOUT THE
PA'S PROGRAM AND THEY DO LESS
THAN 10% OF THE RECYCLING. THIS
WOULD BE TO FIVE MILLION. TO
HUESO. AND WITH A DUBIOUS
PURPOSE BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
THIS IS GOING MAKE. CENTER
DON'T AND IT TARGETS LOW.
VOLUME CENTERS SMALL CENTERS.
WE NEED LARGER CENTERS. IF THE
BILL WERE AMENDED TO THROW
MONEY AT RECYCLING CENTERS THEY
SHOULD BE TARGETED SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE RECYCLING DESERT'S NOT
FOR THE PLACES WHERE WE HAVE
RECYCLING CENTERS NOW THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW. ALL RECYCLING
CENTERS REDEMPTION CENTERS TO
SHARE THE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS NOT ENOUGH TO
BRING BACK ANYTHING- IN TERMS
OF WHAT THIS- PROGRAM NEEDS
WHICH IS- HUNDREDS OF CENTERS
AND CENTERS SPECIFICALLY IN
AREAS WHERE NOT EXISTS LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO AND HOBBLE SANTA
MONICA WHERE THERE'S A HIGH
RANKED. THE ADVISORY PANEL UP
IS LIKE LETTING THE FOX GUARD
THE CHICKEN COOP REGULATED
ENTITIES HAVE NO BUSINESS
ADVISING REGULATORS- WE HADN'T
BROUGHT THESE CONCERNS TO
CELEBRATE SOME WITH MEMBERS
TENSION AND WE'RE HOPING. YEAH
WE'RE HOPING THAT YOU WILL TAKE
THE INSTRUMENTS TO GET RID OF
THESE BAD PROVISIONS AND DO ONE
THING WHICH IS GIVE MONEY TO
THE RECYCLING CENTERS THAT ARE
NEEDED IN THE DESERT- THIS
BILL- IS A BILL THAT- USE
BUSINESS ONE THAT GIVES AWAY
EVERYTHING TO THE WASTE HAULERS
IN THE GROCERS AND- IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT. IS GOOD FOR
CONSUMERS OR THE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS WITH CONCERNS I'M JEFF
DON THE DON FROM MEETINGS
RECYCLING ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES GOOD MORNING CHAIR IN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEFF DONLEVY
LISTINGS RECYCLING IN
SACRAMENTO INNINGS RESOURCES IN
HAYWARD MEANS OF THE LARGEST C.
R. V. RECYCLER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL TO REFORM
THE BOTTLE BILL. IT BEGINS THE
CONVERSATION ON FIXING THE
CURRENT BOTTLE BILLS NUMEROUS
PROBLEMS WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
A FEW ITEMS IN THE BILL SUMMER
GOOD SUMMER NOT NEEDED IN ONE
ITEM WOULD HAVE DEVASTATING
RESULTS ON MANY RECYCLING
CENTERS. AND POSSIBLY CAUSE
MORE CLOSURES IN ALREADY
UNDERSERVED AREAS. TODAY
THERE'S THIRTY SIX COUNTIES
WITH LESS THAN A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR RECYCLING CENTERS
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE AREAS
THAT NEED HELP NOT ALL
RECYCLING CENTERS. AB FIFTY
FOUR MAINLY HELPS LOW VOLUME
RECYCLING CENTERS AND BY
HELPING ALL LOW VOLUME
RECYCLING CENTERS IT'S A BASIC
MISUNDERSTANDING OF THE REAL
PROBLEM IS THAT THE REAL
PROBLEMS IN THE BOTTLE BILL. WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
UNDERSERVED AREAS BRINGING
CONVENIENCE PACKED ALL
CALIFORNIANS. MEANS IN MANY
OTHER RECYCLING CENTERS WILL
RESPOND WILL SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THAT HELPS IMPROVE
THE PROGRAM FOR CONSUMERS
DELEGATES AUTHORITY TO MAKE
CHANGES TO CAL RECYCLE-
PREFERABLY DIRECTOR WAGNER GIVE
HER THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES. AND HELP BRING
CONVENIENCE BACK TO THE
CONSUMERS WE LIKE TO SEE AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR MOVE
FORWARD AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MEETING WITH THE AUTHOR TO
BRING MAJOR REFORMS OF THE
BOTTLE BILLS THAT WILL HELP ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WERE ALLOWED TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. THANK
YOU PARENTS SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTY FIFTY FOUR FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AN EXTRA BOTTLE LINE OF
ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS CREDIBILITY DOT COM
BEHALF OF STOP WASTE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE A SUPPORT AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL WE THINK
THE WOMEN'S ALONG WAY TO
IMPROVING IT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORED
REFINED IT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE COMMON. AND
MENTION TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING I'M SURE
AND MEMBERS OF HIS DANIEL LYNCH
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS WE HAVE
EIGHT. AMENDED COMMISSION AND
WHAT YOU THINK MISTER BLOOM
YOUR STAFF MET COMMITTEE TEAR
OPEN AT TO CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW THE CORD CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND ARE AMENDMENTS ARE
OUTLINED IN THE LETTER IT IS
COMMITTEE SHOULD RECEIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GOAL
LINE OF ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT OVER LINE OF ONE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS DENNIS I'LL BE RUNNING
A HALF OF ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION
WE SUPPORT- OF LEGISLATION AND
LOOK TOWARD WORKING WITH THE
OFFER ON. OTHER ISSUES
INCLUDING HAVING COMMINGLED
GREAT MOTHER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING REBEKAH BATH IN
THE APP OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND MEXICO
LINE OF ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING CARE
MEMBERS- GENEVIEVE ADDED ON ON
BEHALF OF THE CLEAN FEES
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT
OF AB. FIFTY FOUR FIFTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU M. AND I'M SURE WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE I'M
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAR AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE
WHICH I KNOW IS CHALLENGING
AND- MULTIFACETED BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE SIR
WELCOME- I DO I WHAT I DID IT
WAS INTERESTING YOUR FIRST
WITNESS AT- I THINK HE SAID
SOMETHING LIKE EIGHTY FIVE.
RECYCLING IS 85% EFFECTIVE- IN
IN A ONE TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND RATIO POPULATION B. A
ONE RECYCLING CENTER FOR TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE MIGHT BE
THINKING ABOUT FOR HUMBOLDT
COUNTY HAS A HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE AND NONE
SO I DO WONDER WHAT'S GOING ON
ACTUALLY I DON'T HAVE TO WONDER
TOO FAR BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
SOME OF THAT'S JUST ENDING UP
IN THE REGULAR WAY STREAM SO.
SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD YOU KNOW
I RECOGNIZE THAT- IN LARGE IN
LARGER METROPOLITAN AREAS WHERE
DID DIP THE TRANSPORTATION FROM
ONE ENTITY TO ANOTHER IN THE
SITE AND THE PROCESS IS FAIRLY
IT COULD BE FAIRLY SHORT IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES LIKE HUMBOLDT
TRINITY COUNTY IT'S NOT AND SO
I WOULD HOPE THAT AT SOME
POINT- WE CAN CONSIDER
TRANSPORTATION COSTS- WASTE
MANAGEMENT AGENCIES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE THAT ARE TRYING TO
TRYING TO DO THIS RECYCLING-
THAT IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BIGGEST CHALLENGES FOR THEM-
PEOPLE THINK THAT WE LIVE IN A
RURAL AREA AND MAYBE THE COST
OF YOU MIGHT BE LESS IS
ACTUALLY MORE- AND- THE
DISTANCES- WHILE ON THE WHILE
ON THE MAP TO LOOK VERY FAR
THEY'RE OFTEN RUGGED TO MAKE
TERRAIN AND DIFFICULT-
DIFFICULT TO TRANSPORT SO I
JUST HOPE THAT WE COULD
CONSIDER TRANSPORTATION COSTS-
IN IN FUTURE IN THE FUTURE.
PARTS OF THIS THAT THIS PROCESS
OF THANK YOU SIR YOU'RE WELCOME
WILL BE. HAPPY TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT. ANY OTHER QUESTION
FROM MEMBERS. HE WILL YOU BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS HAVE NOT YES YOU
SAID THAT IN YOUR STATEMENT
OKAY THINK I'M A GOOD AND WE GO
OKAY AND WHERE WE WILL OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU I JUST WANTED
TO VERIFY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR WHAT IS
REALLY AT I THINK AND URGENT
FIX AFTER A SEVEN YEARS OF
DECLINING RECYCLING RATES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER OUT BUT-
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA THE MOTION. IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM TEN
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM MEMBERS
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORIDA. LARA
AYE CHAU CHAU HI FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I SEE A- RCI MATHIS.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI.
SARTORIO ART FAIR T<c.cyan> STONE</c>
STONE I WOULD WOOD I. NINE ZERO
NINE ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT
THANK YOU I'M NEXT WE HAVE. AB
NINE EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES FIRST EXCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW WILDFIRES
HAVE CREATED TREMENDOUS IMPACTS
ON ON CALIFORNIANS OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS. OUR STATE
IS DOING MORE THAN EVER TO
SOLVE THIS ISSUE BUT CHALLENGES
ARE MOUNTING EVERY YEAR. EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY ONE WILL CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE SAFE COUNCIL.
INDEPENDENT BODY THAT CAN OFFER
EXPERT RECOMMENDATIONS TO
COORDINATE AND STREAMLINE THE
RAY OF. PROGRAMS AND FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITIES FOR
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION AND
MITIGATION. OVER THE LAST YEAR
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
MANY WELL FOR FIRE STAKEHOLDERS
AND I HEARD A CONSISTENT NEED
FOR AID. ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL
OR LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS AB
NINETY ONE IS UNIQUE AMONG THE
MANY EFFORTS- WELL FOR FIRE
FRONTS WHICH I APPLAUD EACH AND
EVERYONE WHO'S DOING SO. AND
FILLS A CRITICAL NEED FOR THAT
FOR THAT FOR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETY ONE I HAVE
TO EXPERT WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT HELLO ASK THEM TO BE
BRIEF. THE FIRST IS KATE DARGAN
A RETIRED CALIFORNIA STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. CO CHAIR OF THE
NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA FIRE SAFE
COUNCIL AND THE SOURCE FOR THIS
IDEA. AND ANTHONY TANNER HILL
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IS UP HERE ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT THANK
YOU SO WE'RE READY FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I WANT TO
REMIND EACH WITNESS THAT YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO PROVIDE
YOUR TESTIMONY AND WE WILL
START WITH KATE DARGAN. HELLO
ASSEMBLY- TAX RECEIPTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS KATE JUST CHECKING TO
MAKE SURE I'M ALIVE AND HEARD
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK YOU
SO YES- THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
SAFE COUNCIL WILL CLEAR UP ANY
NAME CONFUSION HERE IN A MOMENT
IF IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY ONE AND APPRECIATE
AUTHOR FRASIER'S- WILLINGNESS
TO BRING THIS FORWARD. THE END
OF THE NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA
FIRE STATE COUNCIL IS A
STATEWIDE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
AND PREVENTION ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. WE CREATED- BACK IN THE
ORIGIN DAYS WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
AND THEN ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO
BECAME A NONPROFIT ASSOCIATION
DEDICATED TO PASSING GRANTS
THROUGH AND ADVOCATING FOR THE
CREATION OF FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN THAT TIME WE
HAVE DISTRIBUTED OVER ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
GRANTS FOR WILDFIRE RESILIENCY
CREATED OVER TWO HUNDRED LOCAL
FIRE SAFE COUNCIL SUPPORTED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FIRE WHITE
NEIGHBORHOODS TO DEPRESS THAT
PROGRAM. IN GENERAL ADVOCATED-
BOTH AT SACRAMENTO AND AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL FOR US FINDING AND
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT FOR
WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PREPAREDNESS AND RESILIENCY. SO
A LONGTIME ADVOCATE OF THE MANY
THINGS. THE COMMITTEE IS
EXAMINING TODAY. WE BELIEVE
THAT CAL. BUT CONTINUE TO TAKE
BOLD. WHILE TRY REVEALING IS
NOW GOING TO COME EASILY IS NOT
GOING TO COME CHEAP. AND IT IS
GOING TO REQUIRE AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF LIFT FROM EVERYONE
ENGAGED- FROM MANY MANY
DIFFERENT ANGLES. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL WILL HELP
INCREASE THE COLLABORATIVE
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO
OCCUR. IT WILL HELP REDUCE
CONFLICT IT WILL HELP ALIGN
POLICIES AND IT WILL HELP
DEVELOP NEW IDEAS FOR MANY
DIVERSE VOICES AND PERSPECTIVES
THERE NEEDED TO ADDRESS THIS
COMPLEX ISSUE. THE DIVERSE
VOICES INCLUDE SAFETY ENTITIES.
INSURANCE SECTOR SOCIAL
SERVICES ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
PLANNING BUILDING LAND MANAGERS
WON'T USE PLANNERS EDUCATORS
AIR AND WATER QUALITY EXPERTS
PUBLIC HEALTH. I MET SCIENTISTS
HOME BUILDERS AND MORE I'M
GOING TO READ YOU A QUICK
EXAMPLE PLEASE WRAP UP THIS
YEAR OVER YEAR TENANTS BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO WHEN ARE
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS OF
EXISTENCE WE BELIEVE THAT.
PUTTING A BODY TOGETHER LIKE
THE MANY OTHER COUNCILS THAT
EXIST WHETHER IT'S THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL THE BIO
DIVERSITY COUNCIL THE STEP
DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IT IS
TIME TO DEVELOP A COORDINATING
MULTI VERSE GROUP. AT THE
NATIONAL RESOURCE AGENCY THAT
CAN WORK ACROSS THE MANY MANY
STAKEHOLDERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU I'M I'M SURE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY CANO I AM
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT OVER
ONE THOUSAND INDEPENDENT LOCAL
AGENCIES AND- AFFILIATE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND WORKERS
SUPPORT AB NINE EIGHTY ONE- AND
THE CREATION OF A STATE LEVEL
CALIFORNIA FIRE SAFE COUNCIL-
WHETHER IT'S A FIRE DISTRICT OR
WATER DISTRICT RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT OPEN
SPACE OR OR PARK DISTRICT. OUR
MEMBERS ARE LITERALLY ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE WILD FIRE
ISSUE. AND ACROSS THE STATE
THEY'RE CONFRONTING THIS ISSUE
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT COME
WITH IT AND DEVELOPING- LOCAL
SOLUTIONS TO PROTECT THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AB EIGHT NINE
EIGHTY ONE WILL GIVE THESE
NUMBERS THEIR CHANCE TO SHARE
ALL THAT HARD WON EXPERTISE AND
HOPEFULLY SHAPE THE FUTURE OF
FIRE PREVENTION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I WOULD LOVE THE
APPROACH AND WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE
INITIATIVE AND INTRODUCING THIS
MEASURE AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OUR NEXT WE
WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES.
YES THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF AB-
NINE EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY ONE. AND MAKE A MOTION
TO SUPPORT. TO PROVIDE OKAY.
THE MANAGER WE HAVE NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME FOR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM I DON'T SEE ANY WITNESSES
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE OF ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I DON'T SEE ANY SO
WE HAVE A MOTION. FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA SECONDED BY SO
YOUR TOTAL. OF THE MOTION IS.
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVAS FIVE
FLORA FLORA I'D CHAU CHAU HI
FRIEDMAN. GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MATHIS MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI THEY ARE CHAU I'D
SAY OUR TO OUR AYE STONE. STONE
I WOULD WOULD I'D- EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT ZERO THAT BLOWS OUT THANK
YOU MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES. I'M
NEXT WE HAVE AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND START WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEDICARE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WHICH ONE
TOWER THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL TO DEVELOP. A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORKS OF THE
STATE AGENCIES CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO ADDRESS OUR
CLIMATE CRISIS. THE IMPACTS OF
THE CLIMATE CRISIS ARE BEING
FELT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA LAST
SUMMER TEMPERATURES IN WOODLAND
HILLS AND MY DISTRICT IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. SEARCHED
AN INCREDIBLE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE DEGREES THE HIGHEST
READING EVER RECORDED IN L. A.
COUNTY. ELEVATED TEMPERATURES
EXPLOSIVE WILDFIRES RISING SEA
LEVELS AND WORSENING DROUGHTS
AND FLOODS ARE GRIM REMINDERS
OF OUR NEW CLIMATE REALITY. AND
A CALL TO ACTION. WELL THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ENACTED VARIOUS
FRAMEWORKS AND ENDORSED VARIOUS
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
CALIFORNIA STILL LACKS
GOVERNANCE PRIORITIZATION AND
METRICS ON CRITICAL PRIORITY
ACTIONS. AND TIMELINES TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE ADAPTATION
GOALS. AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
ADDRESSES THIS GAP BY TASKING
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
WITH DEVELOPING AND
COORDINATING A STRATEGIC
RESILIENCY FRAMEWORK. THAT
MAKES RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PREPARE THE STATE FOR THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CLIMATE IMPACTS.%
IDENTIFY SPECIAL PROTECTIONS
FOR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
INDUSTRIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND
IMPORTANTLY DEVELOPS TIMETABLES
AND METRICS TO MEASURE PROJECTS
IN ACHIEVING THE FRAMEWORK.
THROUGHOUT THIS WORK STATE
AGENCIES WILL PROACTIVELY AND
COLLABORATIVELY ENGAGE WITH
REGIONAL AND LOCAL ENTITIES AS
WELL AS VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
TO ENSURE THAT SOLUTIONS MATCH
THE DIVERSE AND UNIQUE NEEDS OF
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR ARE
READ ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION AND
RONNIE SO MANY WITH SO CAL
THREE FIFTY WHAT WE COULD BY
TAKING THE TURN THE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND THOUGHTFUL
ASSISTANCE. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. EXACTLY
THANK BUCK YEAH THANK YOU BUT
MODERATE. WORKING A READY FOR
WITNESS AND SOME. HELLO FIVE
PEOPLE BEING BETTER. IS THAT IS
THAT ARE IS OLD. YEAH GOOD
MORNING ED SHEERAN IS READ OUT
OF SOME OF THE COMMUNITY NATURE.
OUR ORGANIZATION BASED LA
REGION. AND WERE FOCUSED ON
BREAK DOWN TO NATURE CLICKING
WE WORK AND THEREFORE OUR STAFF
AND THE COMMUNITIES WE WORK
WITH HER ON THE FRONT LINES OF
OUR CLIMATE CRISIS. AND WHILE
WE UNDERSTAND THE STATE IS
DOING A LOT TO DEAL WITH
REDUCING EMISSIONS ARE WE
WORKED ON THE DEAL WITH
ADAPTING TO THE- CHANGES THAT
ARE COMING TO MATTER WHAT.
THEREFORE WE ARE. TODAY AND
DISPENSARY THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. IT'S GOING TO BE DEALING
WITH- AN OVERARCHING POLICIES
THAT THE STATE IS AND HOW WELL
IT HAS A NUMBER OF USEFUL.
POLICIES IN PLACE SPOKE AT O.
PR AND THE RESOURCES AGENCY. WE
THINK THIS MEASURE ALLOWS. THE
STATE TO HAVE A OVERALL.
THOUGHTFUL AND ROBOTS POLICY TO
SAY WE SHOULD BE DOING
ADAPTATION. WE SHOULD HAVE
CLEAR GUIDANCE ON THE
GOVERNANCE AND MANAGEMENT OF
THAT ADAPTATION. WE SHOULD KNOW
WHAT WE'RE ADAPTING TO THEIR
FOR HAVING. AND METRICS IN
PLACE. AND IF THE STATE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT HOW COURTNEY
STAFFORD'S REGIONAL F. A
REGIONAL ACTIVITIES AND WE KNOW
THERE WILL BE OTHER MEASURES
TODAY. IN THIS COMMITTEE
TALKING ABOUT REGIONAL EFFORT.
FINALLY WILL SAY THAT PART IN
PARTICULAR INTEREST IN THIS
MEASURE IT AND ALL ALSO SAID
THAT WHEN WE DEAL WITH CLIMATE
ADAPTATION HEARING CALIFORNIA
WE'RE THINKING WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT. MORAL VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THOSE ARE THE
COMMUNITIES WE WORK AND
THEREFORE IN COURT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MY
NAME IS RAVI SALAS GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MARTY
FELDMAN AND I AM ON THE HEARING
COMMITTEE EXCEL CAL THREE FIFTY
CLIMATE ACTION WHICH ENERGIZED
AND EMPOWERED SEVEN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. THANKS SOLUTIONS
AND CONFRONT THE GROWING
CLIMATE AMERICAN. I AM HONORED
TO BE HERE I THINK IN SUPPORT
EIGHTY THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MANY GABRIEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COULD GET. CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE MOST CLIMATE
CHALLENGED REGIONS IN NORTH
AMERICA YEAH LET ME THINK THE
TYPICALLY IT IS EXPECTED TO
WARM FORTY FIVE DEGREES BY MID
CENTURY AND HERE WE NUMBER OF
DAYS OVER NINETY FIVE GREENWOOD
CONDUCTED ALMOST QUITE GROUP UP
IN SAN FERNANDO AND- SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY. FIND A FIND
PROPER THE LEVEL OF OUR A LOT
CAL. COAST FIVE TO TWENTY FOUR
INCHES. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY FIFTY. TRIED TO
STORM SURGE CAN CAUSE COASTAL
FLOODING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY WHEN BIG WAY TOWARDS
THE CURRENT HIGH TIDE. L. A.
COUNTY ALSO SUFFERS FROM SOME
OF THE WORK AIR POLLUTION IN
THE COUNTRY WHICH IS A PROBLEM
WORKING BY CLIMATE ZONES.
ARCTIC TEMPERATURES HEAT UP THE
CHEMICAL REACTIONS TO CREATE
GROUND LEVEL OZONE THE MAIN
COMPONENT OF SMOG. GROUND LEVEL
OZONE IS LINKED ASTHMA
BRONCHITIS. HEART ATTACKS AND
PREMATURE DEATH. CRITICAL THAT
ARE TAKE ACTION ON CLIMATE.
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR BY
GABRIEL REQUIRE TO STAY TO
COLLABORATE AND GET WITH ME AND-
INCLUDING EIGHT AND- JOINT OUR
AND FUNDING FOR. AND PROMOTE
REGIONAL POLICE PROACTIVE
ENGAGED VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
WITH INSTAGRAM CORDON PLANNING
AND PROJECT DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
HAVE BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHO ARE TO NEED BOB PUTS UNFAIR
CONSEQUENCES FROM LAND USE A
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE TIME AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU EXACT VOTE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU- WE'RE READY FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. IF YOU'RE A PARENT
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO OUR FIRST FINE OF
ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JANET CLARK THREE THREE
FIFTY BALKAN VALLEY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION MAINTENANCE NOT
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOODS LAND
TRUST IN SUPPORT LAPTOP WITH AN
S. REGISTER SUPPORT FOR FRIEND
OF THE L. A. RIVER AND THE
RIVER PROJECT. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MANAGER. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE ANY- WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY
ANY AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I DON'T SEE ANY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. HI
YEAH I JUST- WILL SAY I'M A BIG
BELIEVER THAT THAT WHICH GETS
MEASURED GETS DONE AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE
SOME- SOME BENCHMARKS AND SOME
TIME FRAMES- AND SOME METRICS
TO MEASURE THIS IMPORTANT WORK
AND WHAT THAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- WE HAVE A
MOTION NO I BELIEVE WE DON'T
HAVE. A MOTION CAN I GET. WE DO
I'M SORRY I DID- GARCIA. AND
MCCARTY. OKAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAU THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I AM THIRTEEN AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL. MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE FLORA FLOOR
NOT VOTING CHAU CHAU I FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS.
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI SARATOGA SARATOGA
STONE RIGHT STONE I WOULD WOOD
I. SIX ONE SIX ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU. AB WHILE WE
TRANSITION I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHAT. THIS CALL THE ROLL. ON
THE CONCERT CALENDAR. MEMBERS
THREE OF US HI RIVERSIDE FLORA
FLORIDA I'D CHAU CHAU HI
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA I'D
MATHIS. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI. SORRY ARE TOO HIGH
THEY ARE CHAU ICE STONES. STONE
I WOULD WOULD I. EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT ZERO FIVE NEXT WE HAVE AP
AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND START MISTER MULLIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB EIGHT NINE
SEVENTY TODAY- WOULD LIKE TO
START BY SAYING THAT I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS DONE TO.
IMPROVE THE BILL AND I ACCEPT
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. AS
YOU ALL KNOW CLIMATE CHANGE IS
ALREADY AFFECTING CALIFORNIA.
IT IS ESTIMATED TO DO SO WELL
INTO THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
CURRENT AND PROJECTED IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDE.
INCREASED TEMPERATURE SEA LEVEL
RISE INTENSE WILDFIRES ALTERED
PRECIPITATION PATTERNS
EXCESSIVE FLOODING SEVERE
DROUGHT. IN MORE FREQUENT STORM
EVENTS MANY IMPACTS WILL VARY
BASED ON A COMMUNITIES PHYSICAL
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
CHARACTERISTICS WHICH TEND TO
EXTEND BEYOND CITY OR COUNTY
BOUNDARIES THIS MAKES REGIONAL
COORDINATION BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS. AND
PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES A VITAL
COMPONENT OF THOROUGH
RESILIENCY PLANNING SOME LOCAL
ENTITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
BEGUN THE PROCESS. OF PREPARING
FOR THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE HOWEVER MANY ENTITIES
HAVE NOT BEGUN COORDINATING
THIS REPAIRED AS WITH ADJACENT
ENTITIES IN THE REGION AND SOME
OF NOT BEGUN PLANNING. AT ALL
DUE TO THIS LACK OF COORDINATED
PLANNING THE STATE'S CURRENT
MECHANISM FOR FUNDING
ADAPTATION PROJECTS HAS BEEN
PRIMARILY PIECEMEAL WITH NO
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
COORDINATING ITS INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
RESILIENCY RETURN. AB NINE AB
EIGHT NINE SEVEN RATHER SEEKS
TO FILL THIS GAP. BY
ENCOURAGING AND SUPPORTING
REGIONAL CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PLANNING THAT BUILDS UPON AND
ENHANCES LOCAL ADAPTATION
ACTIONS TO REDUCE CLIMATE
RISKS. FOSTERING COLLABORATION
AMONG LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE
ENTITIES ON ADAPTATION
SOLUTIONS AND DEVELOPING
GUIDANCE FOR POTENTIAL STATE
FEDERAL OR PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
IN FUNDING REGIONAL PRIORITY
ADAPTATION PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE- I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
JOINT AUTHORS ON THE BILL DR
KIRK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT. FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION- ON THIS MEASURE
THEY HAD A NUMBER OF MEASURES
MOVING AND AT THE CHAIR
SUGGESTION- WE COLLABORATED.
WITH THIS MEASURE COMING BEFORE
THE BODY TODAY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY VIA PHONE
AS BRUCE RIORDAN WITH THE BAY
AREA CLIMATE ADAPTATION
NETWORK. AND BRITNEY- BENNETT
C. WITH THE SIERRA BUSINESS
COUNCIL. THANK YOU WE'RE READY
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES.
AIRLINES ARE OPEN. WE'LL START
WITH BRUCE RIORDAN. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIR RIVAS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON PRISONER
NINE THE DIRECTOR OF THE BAY
AREA CLIMATE ADAPTATION NETWORK
THEY CANNOT I ALSO MANAGE THE
CLIMATE READY MISCONSTRUED UC
BERKELEY I SPEAK THIS MORNING
ALMOST THIS AFTERNOON IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN
YOU KNOW AS YOU'RE VERY AWARE
CALIFORNIA INCREASINGLY FACED
WITH SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS FROM
HOTTER GLOBAL CLIMATE OUR
RECORD WILDFIRES YOUR RECORD
PROBLEM RECORD HEAT. AND IN THE
NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE WILL
HAVE RECORDS YOU ALL RIGHT
LEAVING BANKS ARE AND WILL BE
VERY SUBSTANTIAL ON HUMAN
HEALTH ON NATURAL AND WORKING.
LANDS ON INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MORE. GOOD DEAL WITH THE IMPACT
WE NEED A TRUE INTEGRATED CAL.
CLIMATE PROGRAM WE NEED A
STRUCTURE. THAT BRINGS TOGETHER
STATE REGIONAL AND LOCAL
RESOURCES IN THE MOST EQUITABLE
AND COST EFFECTIVE MANNER WE
BELIEVE THAT EIGHT NINE SEVEN
BY FCUSING ON THE REGIONAL
ADAPTATION PLANNING IS A BIG
STEP FORWARD IN CREATING A
STRONG. CALIFORNIA PROGRAM THAT
WE NEED IN A RIGHT NOW PLEASE
AND COUNTIES WATER DISTRICTS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHERS ARE ALREADY TAKING
ACTION TO BUILD. LOCAL CLIMATE
RESILIENCE. EIGHT NINETY
SEVENTH GRADE THOMAS IS THAT IT
WILL BUILD UPON THESE WORKS-
AND ENHANCE THE TITANS TOGETHER
CHINESE LOCAL PROJECTS TOGETHER
IF WE CAN SKILLFULLY COMBINED
LOCAL ADAPTATION WORK. WITH
TRUE COLLABORATIVE REGIONAL
PLANNING NOT JUST GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES BUT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ACADEMICS
REGIONAL STAKEHOLDER NETWORKS
AND OTHERS WE CAN COMBINE THAT.
AND GET STATE SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE WE WILL BE ON OUR WAY.
FINALLY YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A GLOBAL LEADER ON CUTTING
CARBON EMISSIONS FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS THIS DID NOT
HAPPEN BECAUSE WE HOPED. THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND REGIONAL
AGENCIES IN UTILITIES WOULD DO
THE RIGHT THING THAT HAPPENS
BECAUSE WE ARE YOU PASSED AB
THIRTY TWO SB THIRTY TWO EIGHTY
ONE NINETY SEVEN THREE SEVENTY
FIVE. THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD ALL OF THE ABOVE AND
MORE. WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA IN THE SAME WAY
TO NOW BECOME A GLOBAL LEADER
ON CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE SO WE
SUPPORT EIGHT NINE SEVEN IT'S
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
MOVEMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. HELLO AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBER BRINGING IF
YOU WOULD YOU'RE A BIT ACCOUNT.
OF THE TRIPLE BOTTOM ORGAN
SERVING THE ROLE COMMUNITIES
THAT. AND INVITE AT THE YEAR
AND ABOUT AT YOUR BUSINESS
COUNTY AND SUPPORT OF EIGHT
EIGHT NOW SEVEN. S. B. C. IS
THE MANAGING ORGANISED OF THE
FEAR CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
MITIGATION PARTNERSHIP OR
SIERRA CAMP. ORIGINAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE AND MEMBER OF ARC
AT THE ALLIANCE FOR REGIONAL
COLLABORATIVES FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION. HERE CAN'T CAN BE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NONPROFIT
REGIONAL AGENCIES LOCAL EXPERTS
AND BUSINESSES FROM ACROSS THE
REGION TO WORK TOGETHER ON
CLIMATE PLANNING AND ACTION. IN
THE SIERRA AS IN MANY PARTS OF
THE STATE LIMITATION THE
CAPACITY AND COVERAGE REQUIRE
MULTI AGENCY AND MULTI
DIRECTIONAL COLLABORATION.
WITHOUT SUCH COORDINATION THESE
LIMITATIONS WOULD HINDER OUR
COMMUNITY'S EFFORTS TO
MEANINGFULLY PARTICIPATE IN
STATEWIDE COLD. COLD AND
INITIATIVES. AB EIGHT NINE
SEVEN RECOGNIZES THE CHALLENGES
AND MEET THEM BYE BYE BY
PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY IN THE
TYPES OF ENTITIES ELIGIBLE FOR
ORGANIZING REGIONAL CLIMATE
NETWORK AND DEVELOPING CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PLANS. INCLUDING OUR
STATE WILL CERVANTES RIVAL
GOVERNMENT AN EXISTING
COLLABORATIVE. JENNIFER POINT
ARCHINECT COLLABORATIVE OFFER
PRIME EXAMPLES OF A SUCCESSFUL
CLIMATE PLANNING COLLABORATION
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF MORAL
AND URBAN AREAS ALIKE.
SIMILARLY THE GUIDELINES WILL
SUPPLEMENTAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE REQUIRED OPR IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN WILL HELP
ENSURE BALANCE INCLUDING. GAUGE
MEANT OF CALIFORNIANS
UNDERSERVED AREA. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLING
IN ALL THE AUTHORS FOR THE
RESPONSIVENESS TO OUR REGION
MEANS THAT THEY PROVIDED
THROUGHOUT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS BILL. REQUIRED LIKE THE
PROCESSES INCLUDED IN AB EIGHT
NINE SEVEN EVERY CORNER OF OUR
OF OUR EXPENSES TAKING RIGHT WE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL
GO TO WHICH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES. IF YOU IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINE
SEVEN. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI DANIELLE LYNCH I AM OFFERING
THE POOR ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION AND MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT FOR EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF ONE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND THIS IS
JACK PARKS RETREATED YOU
THOUGHT CAN VALLEY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO. WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF ALL ONE OF THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
MONIQUE MARS IN A CLIMATE
ACTION CAMPAIGN AND THE SAN
DIEGO GREEN AND YELLOW LINES
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FOR THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME MANAGER. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN THE HEARING ROOM. I DON'T
SEE ANY WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE OF ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT
THINK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JUST A JUST A COMMENT FIRST
BALL- I LIKE YOUR APPROACH-
IT'S A LOT LIKE WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO RELATED TO FIRE
PREVENTION AND AGENCIES SO I
REALLY LIKE YOUR PRO CHEER AND-
SHOULD THE BILL PASS OUT OF
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR. OF THE TEST.
THANK YOU. I'VE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS- WIDE LIKE THAT THANK
YOU AND THE JOINT AUTHORS FOR
COMING TOGETHER AND
COLLABORATING I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED IN YOUR- EXHORTATION
THAT I ASKED THE AUTHORS TO
COME TOGETHER AND- YOU DID
SUCCESSFULLY- AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT IT SHOWS A TRUE
COLLABORATION. AMONG SEVERAL
MEMBERS- IN THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE SO THANK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. JUST AGAIN THANK
YOU MEDICARE FOR ENCOURAGING-
OUR CONVERSATIONS AND- THE HOPE
HERE IS THAT WE'RE
INCENTIVIZING- THE RIGHT KIND
OF PLANNING ACROSS THE STATE TO
GET IN FRONT OF WHAT WE HOPE
WILL BE- POTENTIALLY SOME BOND
MONEY AT THE STATE LEVEL
POTENTIALLY- FEDERAL DOLLARS
AROUND CLIMATE RESILIENCE I
THINK THERE'S AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA. YEAH WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THESE REGIONS ARE
DOING THE APPROPRIATE KIND OF
PLANNING AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.TO
THE MOTION OF. MADE BY OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN MEMBERS
THREE OF US HI RIVERSIDE FLOOR.
FLORIDA VOTING CHAU CHAU FIVE
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MATHIS. MCCARTY MCCARTY I
MURATSUCHI SAY ARTURO NOVEL
THEY ARE NOT VOTING. STONE
STONE I WOULD WOULD I. SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO THAT BLOWS OUT THANK
YOU. C. AT THE NEXT. WE HAVE AB
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HI CONTINUING ON THE
TOPIC OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
PREPARING CALIFORNIA FOR THE
THREAT OF SEA LEVEL RISE I AM I
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIXTY SEVEN I
WHICH ENSURES THAT C. LEVEL
RISE AND ALICE HE'S ARE
INCLUDED WHEN STATE AGENCIES
PLAN FOR AND FIND STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AT THE
CALIFORNIA COAST AS WE KNOW IS
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY MILES
OF BREATHTAKING BEAUTY IT IS
HOME TO SOME 70% OF
CALIFORNIANS IT IS A CRITICAL
ENGINE EVER STATE'S ECONOMY AND
IT IS YOU I BELIEVE JUST HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUE MISTER MULLIN
IT IS ALL UNDER THREAT FROM
SEALEVEL RISE. EFFECTIVELY
PREPARING FOR SEA LEVEL RISE
WILL ENABLE OUR STATE TO
NAVIGATE THE PHYSICAL AND
ECONOMIC THREATS EVER RISING
SEAS ODD THOUGH IT IS WELL
KNOWN THAT SEA LEVEL RISE IS A
LOOMING THREAT NOT ALL OF OUR
STATE AGENCIES EXPLICITLY
CONDUCTED C. LEVEL RISE
ANALYSES WHEN PLANNING
MAINTAINING AND FINDING NEW AND
EXPANDED INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS
MEANS THAT THE STATE IS FUNDING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
COULD QUITE LITERALLY BE
UNDERWATER AND DIVERTING PUBLIC
FUNDS THAT COULD OTHERWISE
SUPPORT LOCAL REGIONAL PLANNING
AND ADAPTATION EFFORTS- AS
DECEMBER IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE RELEASED A REPORT WHICH
OUTLINED THE IMPACTS AND ISSUES
FACING OUR STATE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RELATED TO
SEA LEVEL RISE. AMONG A NUMBER
OF RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
REPORT I WON INCLUDED THE
CREATION AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
A STANDARD METHODOLOGY FOR AT
THE CONDUCTING OF SEA LEVEL
RISE ANALYSES TO AB SIXTY SEVEN
LOOKS TO IMPLEMENT THAT
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE L. A.
THE REPORT AND BETTER PREPARE
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS BY-
ESTABLISHING A MULTI AGENCY
GROUP A WORKING GROUP TO
PROVIDE A STANDARD METHODOLOGY
FOR CONDUCTING SEA LEVEL RISE
ANALYSES CONSISTING OF
RECOMMENDED POLICIES
RESOLUTIONS PROJECTS. AND MORE
AND REQUIRING ALL STATE AGE TO
BE USING THE STANDARD
METHODOLOGY MOVING FORWARD.
WITH THAT I AM PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE OUR OUR SPONSOR FOR
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. AT CAITLYN
COLUSA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE. THANK
YOU- WERE READY FOR THE WITNESS
IN SUPPORT MODERATOR Q. PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE. YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WONDERFUL
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR RIVAS
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CAITLYN COOLEY LATIN
THE POLICY MANAGER FOR TH
CALIFORNIA CHRIS PIEPER
ALLIANCE WHICH PROUD TO PARTNER
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
PETRIE-NORRIS. BONSER AB SIXTY
SEVEN. A QUICK DESCRIBED I MEAN
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT ON FETAL RIGHTS AND
REITERATED IN ITS AUGUST TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT DOES NOT NEXT
DECADE IS A CRUCIAL TIME TO
PREPARE AND PLAN. FOR CHANGES
ALONG THE CALIFORNIA COAST
BEFORE MARK STREAMING MORE
EXPENSIVE. SOLUTION ARE THE
ONLY AVAILABLE OPTION. THE FELT
LEADER OCEAN HOW. ALONG OTHER
C. A. WITH EXPERTISE IN SALEM
RIGHTS TO CREATE. METHODOLOGY
TO BE USED BY AGENCIES BEFORE
APPROVING STATE PLANS FOR NEW
OR EXPANDED INFRASTRUCTURE
LOCATED IN P. LEVEL RISE IN THE
NATION BAM. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE STATE IS RESPONSIBLE AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE STEWARDS OF
PUBLIC FUNDS. THIS METHODOLOGY
IS NOT ONLY NEEDED TO INSURE
THAT ALL AGENCIES CONDUCTED
ABOUT THIS. BUDGET TO ENSURE
THE FEMALES THIS IS CONDUCTED
CONSISTENTLY. BETWEEN ATARI AND
BOTH BETWEEN. AND WITHIN THE
STATE AGENCIES. SB SIX SEVEN
MAKE THE METHOD ALL AVAIL TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS A RESOURCE
BUT DOES NOT MANDATE THAT THIS
AMOUNTS TO BE USED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. FINALLY THIS BILL
IS DESIGNED TO ADVANCE EXISTING
COORDINATION AND PLANNING
EFFORTS RELATED TO C. LEVEL
RISE. WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY TO ENSURE THAT STATE
AGENCIES ARE INFORMED OF THE
ECONOMIC RISK RISK POSED BY SEA
LEVEL RISE. THE NEW YORK STATED
IT WAS STRUCTURED BEFORE STATE
FUNDS ARE APPROVED. TO
ULTIMATELY ENSURE THAT THE
STATE IS RESPONSIBLE STEWARD OF
PUBLIC FUNDS. THANK YOU
ALTHOUGH TO REGISTER SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTY SEVEN. ON BEHALF OF
THE SURFRIDER FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA COASTAL PROTECTION
NETWORK IN GREENBELT ALLIANCE.
THANK YOU NEXT ONE OR TWO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES. IF YOU IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY SEVEN.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LOT OF ONE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RICO MASTRODONATO WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
IMPORTANT SMART BILL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS IS DANIELLE
LYNCH REFERENCE- OFFERING THE
COR ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION ON
EIGHTY SIX SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SHARON STONE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF ONE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AARON RODRIGUEZ UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE SECOND
CHAPTER IN HER CAREER. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME AN OBJECT THANK
YOU- ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY
ANY WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE I'VE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I DON'T SEE ANY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE. THE
MOTION. THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM SIXTEEN AB
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA I'D CHAU
CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN. GARCIA
GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS SIDE
MCCARTY RIGHT MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI SAY ARE CHAU I SAY
OUR TO OUR EYES STONE. STONE I
WOULD WOOD I. NINE ZERO K. NINE
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
I THINK I MIGHT BE NEXT YES YOU
ARE NEXT AB SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY WELL
THANK YOU FOR THAT LINE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTY TWO ON THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS TO CUT GREEN TAPE FOR
COASTAL ADAPTATION PROGRAMS ON
THE COAST WE JUST TALKED ABOUT-
WHAT HUGE THREAT C. LEVEL RISE
IS CHAR COAST IN OUR COASTAL
ECONOMIES AND THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT THERE ARE PROMISING
STRATEGIES TO HELP US COMBAT
THE THREAT OF SEA LEVEL RISE
AND- I ONE OF THE STRATEGIES
INCLUDES NATURE BASED CORAL
COASTAL ADAPTATION INITIATIVES.
SUCH AS REPLACING SHORELINE
ARMORING WITH LIVING SHORELINES
CREATING AND REHABILITATING
TIDAL MARSHES TO BUFFER
INCREASING TIDES AND USING
NATURAL BREAKWATERS OF OYSTERS
AND OTHERS TO DISSIPATE WAVE
ACTION- HOWEVER COASTAL
ADAPTATION INITIATIVES LIKE
THIS SPACE MANY CHALLENGES
INCLUDING HIGH COST A LACK OF
AVAILABLE RESOURCES AND A
HIGHLY COMPLICATED APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR COASTAL ADAPTATION
WORK. SOMETIMES PROJECTS THAT
MAY TAKE ONLY WEEKS TO
IMPLEMENT CAN TAKE LITERALLY
YEARS TO PERMIT AND WHILE THE
STATE'S DOWN BAYERN MENTAL
PERMITTING SYSTEM IS DESIGNED
TO PROTECT VALUABLE PUBLIC
TRUST RESOURCES AND IS IT A
ABSOLUTE PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE
HOWEVER THE CURRENT PROTESTS
PROTRACTED AND COORDINATED
REVIEW PROCESS IS CAUSING
UNNECESSARY DELAYS FOR REALLY
VALUABLE AND NECESSARY COASTAL
ADAPTATION WORK AND HINDERING
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES SO AB
SEVENTY TWO IS THAT SEEKING TO
CUT GREEN TAPE BY DIRECTING THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. TO EVALUATE REVIEW AND
IMPLEMENT A MORE COORDINATED
AND EFFICIENT REGULATORY REVIEW
PROCESS FOR COASTAL ADAPTATION
PROJECTS AT THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT THE VALUABLE TIME
EXPERTISE AND RESOURCES OF OUR
LEADING SCIENTISTS WORKING TO
COMBAT SEA LEVEL RISE OR SPENT.
ON SOLUTIONS NOT NAVIGATING IN
THE ACT THE- UPSET WITH THAT
PLEASE TO INTRODUCE. FOR
SUPPORT TESTIMONY I WE'VE GOT
JENNIFER SAVAGE FROM THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION AND DR
CHRISTINE RICK WITCHCRAFT. FIVE
FROM CSU LONG BEACH. HEY. WE
HAVE I THINK YOU CAN EXPECT
THAT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI OKAY
HI SORRY GOOD MORNING TERRY THE
THIRD AFTERNOON TERRY THAT.
MANY MEMBERS AND TOPICS WITH
THE THIRD FIGHTER FOUNDATION A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING ABOUT
THE S. AND BEACHES AND WAIT FOR
ALL PEOPLE WE THINK YOUR
DEPARTMENT AT SEVENTY TWO
TODAY. MORE THAN 70% OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS LIVE WORK
AND PLAY BECAUSE OF COUNTY FOR
ALMOST 86% OF THE STATE'S TOTAL
PRESS THAT THE PRODUCT IS
GENERATED I'M THRILLED FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
ENTIRETY OF THE STATE AT THE
CONDITION OF THE OCEAN BEACH IS
A VERY IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA
QUALITY OF LIFE. BUT AS WE'VE
HEARD ARTICLE HABITAT ARMENIAN
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES ARE
UNDER PROFOUND THREAT AND IT
OPERATES IN TWENTY NINETEEN
ELLIOTT DETAILS THAT URGENT
NEED FOR MEANINGFUL CAN OPERATE
ADAPTATION PLANNING CALLED FOR
THE STATE. BENEFIT A BENEFIT AT
PART THAT PROTECT PUBLIC REPORT
THAT YEAH TO CREDIT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF VULNERABLE.
COMMUNITIES RIGHT OFF NOTED THE
PROJECT EIGHT MINUTES.
INCLUDING AND I BEFORE. AND A
LINK BECAUSE- APPROVAL PROCESS.
TO ADDRESS THE THREAT LEVEL
RIGHT THE URGENCY BECAUSE BEING
MY IMPROVE THE CURRENT USED.
EVALUABLE PLANET PROJECT. IF
THE LINE THE FINANCIAL A-
HAVING PREPAID THE NEXT DAY.
WHICH IS DESIGNED MAINTAIN
STATE. FARM AND ALLSTATE POLICY
THE CASE GALLAGHER FIVE
SEPARATE SINCE HABITS.
IMPERILED ECO. AB DE KIDS THE
PART BOTH THE STATE ON RECORD.
FIFTY LEVEL RIGHT PLANNING AND
AGENCIES YEAH THAT FIVE Q. OKAY
LOCAL. BUT LIKE EIGHTY ALL
THEIR CARE ABOUT THE HEALTH CAL
BECAUSE- WE DID ABOUT ALL OF
THAT. WE CANNOT AFFORD PUT OFF
MANY FORTY. HIDING IN A LONG.
WE RESPECT URGE I. I'M AT
SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. LIKELY I'M
INTERESTED IN HOW HUMAN
ACTIVITIES AFFECT THE ORGANISMS
THAT CAN LIVE IN WETLANDS AND
HELP US AND THAT IN TURN
AFFECTS THE COMMUNITIES. OF
HUMANS THAT LIVED BEHIND
WETLANDS- IN ADDITION TO
DESCRIBING THE IMPACT OF HUMAN
ACTIVITIES ON BATTLIN. I AM
INTERESTED IN DESIGNING REST
SOLUTIONS THAT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED TO IMPROVE THE
ECOSYSTEM ITSELF. THAT'S WHAT
I'M OFTEN APPLYING FOR A MYRIAD
OF PERMIT SUPPORT RESEARCH AND
IN BECAUSE THE REST STRATEGY. I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED
AB SEVENTY. IN THAT IT WILL
MORE QUICKLY NAY AND HOPEFULLY
EFFICIENT. TO FACILITATE COULD
TO ADD UP PERMITTING. I'M PART
OF THE ASIDE WHO HAVE ADMITTED
THAT COULD SEA LEVEL RISE IN IN
AND IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
DESIGN PROMISING STRATEGIES
LIKE LIVING SHORELINES THAT CAN
COMBAT DUTY THAT WILL RISE. SO
MOVING TRIED LIKE MY THAT ARE
WE PROJECT LARGER SCALE
REGIONAL PROJECT. CAN BE COMP
ESPECIALLY A THE APPROVE
PROCESS. WHEN I DO APPLY
RESEARCH PURPOSE- FOR CO ADDED
RE I HAVE TO COMMIT SEPPUKU AT.
ALREADY STATE. EACH AGENCY THAT
DOES UNDER ITS OWN CAREFUL
REVIEW. AND WHILE WE ARE THE
IMPORTANT OF THIS CAN OVER AND
COLLAB WITH RESOURCE. IS OFTEN
KEY BE TO NOT AS AN APPLE. AN
COMMAND MORE HAVING A BARRIER
CARRYING OUT RESEARCH AND AFTER
PLANNING. SO I THINK THAT AB SO
TWO IS A GOOD TO BARRIERS KERR
THOUGHT. PROJECTS ARE STILL
PROVIDING THE NEXT. IN STRONG
PROTECT THAT ARE COULD RESOURCE
AND IN. NEEDS TO. THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU I'M NEXT ONE TODAY WHAT. IN
SUPPORT OP. PLEASE OF THE PHONE
LINE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
SUPPORT OR I. OF A SEVENTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR RICO MASTRODONATO
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN THEIR APPEARANCE
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. FOR AB.
SEVENTY TWO. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM I
DON'T SEE ANY ANY WITNESSES AT
THE REMOTE LOCATION. THERE ARE
NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I DON'T SEE
ANY- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TOAPPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM SEVENTEEN
AB SEVENTY TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE FLORA. FLORA I CHAU
CHAU I'VE READ. GARCIA GARCIA I.
MATHIS I. MIKE AYE MURATSUCHI
SAY ARE CHAU HI THEY ARE TO OUR
STONE STONE I WOULD. WOULD I.
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO NINE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TOWARDS
PRESENT- AB NINE FIVE MEMBER
CHAO. YEAH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ON MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SO
AB THIRTY NINE WOULD CODIFY THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA CLIMATE
INSTITUTE TO ACCELERATE CLIMATE
ACTION THROUGH COOPERATIVE
EFFORTS AND EXCHANGES BETWEEN
TWO OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST THE
I CANNOT OF POWERS AND MAJOR
EMITTERS OF GREENHOUSE GASES
CALIFORNIA AND CHINA- THERE ARE
MANY SERIOUS THREATS WE FACE-
THAT AREN'T CONSTRAINED BY
NATIONAL BORDERS AND AFFECT
EVERYONE AROUND THE WORLD TO
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
MADE THAT CLEAR. THE CLIMATE
CHANGE CRISIS IS NO DIFFERENT.
TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND NOW REDUCE EMISSIONS WE
MUST. ALL HAVE STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS AROUND THE WORLD
IN TWENTY NINETEEN FORMER
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR
HELPED LAUNCH THE CALIFORNIA
CHINA CLIMATE INSTITUTE TO
PROMOTE CLIMATE ACTION THROUGH
JOINT RESEARCH. TRAINING AND
DIALOGUE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
CHINA. IN FACT ONE OF A BROWN
TESTIFIED AT THE PREVIOUS-
COMMITTEE HEARING AND HIS
SUPPORT LEADERS ALSO ATTACHED
TO ALL THE ANALYSIS OF TODAY'S-
COMMITTEE HEARING. THE
INSTITUTE IS PARTNERING WITH
THE LEADING ACADEMIC AND
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES IN CHINA
AND PROVIDING A PLATFORM TO
BUILD THE THESE ORIGINALLY
NEEDED PARTNERSHIPS. THE
INSTITUTE ADVANCES JOINT POLICY
RESEARCH ON MAJOR CLIMATE
ISSUES INCLUDING LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES CARBON PRICING.
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE SUSTAINABLE LAND USE
AND CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE AND
A LONG TERM CLIMATE GOAL
SETTING AND POLICY ENFORCEMENT.
BY PASSING AB THIRTEEN AND
FORMALIZING THIS- D. INSTITUTE
IN STATE LAW THE LEGISLATURE
KANSEN A STRONG MESSAGE THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE WAY TO REVERSE.
CLIMATE CHANGE BY ADVANCING
JOINT CLIMATE RESEARCH SO
THROUGH COLLABORATION I BELIEVE
I HAVE ALL ONE WITNESS SET TO
TESTIFY TODAY- THAT IS- NIKITA
CORRADI WITH THE NOT- NOW. NOW
RESOURCE THE COUNCIL. OF TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. I HAVE
MODERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN THE
FOR THE WITNESS AND. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU ME YES.
GREAT I THINK WE CAN NOT IN
TURN ON TO BECOME THAT THE NICK
YEAH BUT AND REACHED DEFENSE
COUNCIL ENERGY DECREASES WITH
EIGHTY NINE TO WHICH WOULD. A
LOT OF CHINA I'M ADDICTED TO
SERVE THINK BUT THE PURPOSE OF
THE CLIMATE POLICY ONE OF THE
FOR AND NON STILL IT ENERGY AND-
THREE HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING
SUSTAINABLE TO THE BAKER TECH
AND BE EXPERTISE FROM OUR
TWENTY. BUT NOW NINETY THREE
THANK WITH THE WIDER OF TRY AND
PARTNERS DIFFICULT HE
EXCHANGERS AND LEARNING ABOUT
INNOVATIVE POLICY TO AND
INTRODUCING DEMONSTRATE THAT
CRACK IN EVERYTHING FROM BETTER
EFFICIENCY CLEAN. POLLUTION
CONTROL WHILE CONCERT AND LOW
CARB URBAN AT THE- FOR EXAMPLE
WORKED WITH CHINA COURTS TO
BEGIN TO REDUCE AND YOU MANY OF
THE LESSONS LEARNED AT THE OF
LOS ANGELES AND LONG BEACH.
MUCH LIKE ENERGY PEOPLE TRYING
CAL CHINA CLIMATE MISSION
PREDICATED ON RECOGNITION THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL ARE CAN BY YOUR
BORDERS WE SEE GREAT VALUE IN
AND SPOKE UNTIL. REITER PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. WE WILL GO TO THE LINE
OF ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DEVELOP
PILOTS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY NINE AND WE WOULD ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE BY OUR COLLEAGUE AND
ENERGY SEAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN IT'S ONE
ANOTHER ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. OF AB. THIRTY NINE.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. I DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM I DON'T SEE ANY
ANY WITNESSES WITNESSES AT. THE
REMOTE LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE
OF ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I DON'T SEE
ANY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
WANT TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I THINK WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS- PRETTY MUCH IN
LINE WITH WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS DOING. IN A SENSE
THAT IN FACT TODAY I BELIEVE OF
THE CLIMATE AND WHITE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THAT JOHN KERRY
IS VISITING CHINA TODAY IN
FACT- DISCUSSING CLIMATE-
ISSUES SO I THINK WE'RE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK SO WE GOT THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I BELIEVE
I DON'T HAVE A MOTION. SEVEN
OKAY WE HAVE MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I TO MAKE TíNH AB THIRTY
NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA. FLOOR NOT VOTING. CHAU
FIVE CHAU HI FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I SAW YOUR TOTAL
CERTONA VOTING STONE. STONE I
WOULD. WOULD I. THANK YOU VERY
ZERO EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT I BELIEVE WE HAVE A FEW
BILLS ON CALL AND SOME THAT
MEMBERS NEED TO ADD ON. IS THAT
CORRECT CORRECT YES WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO GO THROUGH EVERY
ITEM LET'S GO THROUGH EVERY
ITEMS OKAY. GIVE ME A SECOND.
OKAY ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT- EIGHT ZERO WITCHER
VOTING I. ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN RIGHT FRIEDMAN I THIS.
MATHIS III MARTUCCI ROUTE TO GI.
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO. I
DON'T ONE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX CARILLO DO PASSED REFER TO
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. CURRENT
VOTE FIVE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I. ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE GARCIA. GARCIA NOT
VOTING MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI WELL TO DO NOT
VOTING STONE. STONE NO WOULD
WOULD I. EIGHT ONE EIGHT ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT. I AM TO AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. MOTION IS TO
PASS REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FORTY
THREE WITH THE TROUBLESHOOTING
I. ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU. CHAU
AYE GARCIA. GARCIA HI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI WELL TO
GI. EIGHT THREE EIGHT THREE
THAT VOTE THE BILL IS OUT. I AM
THREE AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
BUYS MEMBER FRIEDMAN DO PASSED
ON REFER TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE FORTY THREE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU. CHOW I'D GARCIA
GARCIA I MURATSUCHI. RIGHT TO
GI STONE. STONE AYE EIGHT THREE
EIGHT THREE THAT BILL IS OUT. I
DON'T FIVE AB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM. TO
PASS A REFER TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU. CHAU
GARCIA GARCIA I RIGHT TO CHOOSE
MURATSUCHI I. EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT. IDM SIX
EIGHTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD. DO PASSED AS AMENDED IN
REFER TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTERS NINETY
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS GARCIA.
GARCIA I MURATSUCHI ROAD TO GI
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT. IDM SEVEN AB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD DO PASSED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. TWO GI
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO LEVEL
IS OUT. I AM EIGHT AB EIGHT
TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SIX TO
TWO AT THE CHAIR VOTING I.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORIDA LARA AYE
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO GI. NINE
TWO NINE TWO THAT BILL IS OUT.
I DO NINE AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. DO
PASSED AS AMENDED IN REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERR
ABOUT SIX TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I. ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORIDA. FLOOR NOT VOTING.
MATHIS. MATHIS NOT VOTING
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
RIGHT TO GI. EIGHT ONE. EIGHT
ONE THAT BILL IS OUT. THE ITEM
TEN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERR
ABOUT NINE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
MATHIS. MATHIS I MURATSUCHI
READ TO GI ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO THAT PULLS OUT ITEM TWELVE
AB NINE EIGHTY ONE. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MATHIS MATHIS II
MARTUCCI ROUTE TO GI. ELEVEN
ZERO. I DON'T THIRTEEN AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GREAT GABRIEL DO
PASSED REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SIX TO
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I MATHIS. MATHIS NO.
MURATSUCHI AT TGI. EIGHT TWO
EIGHT FIVE DOLLARS OUT OF
FIFTY. THIS ITEM FOURTEEN AB
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN TO PASS
AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO WITH%
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I'M
MATHIS. MATHIS NOW MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I. EIGHT ONE FOR.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB SIXTY SEVEN
PETRIE-NORRIS TO PASS REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE- ABOUT
NINE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I MURATSUCHI
READ TO GI ELEVEN ZERO. I AM
SEVENTEEN AB SEVENTY TWO
PETRIE-NORRIS TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. OUR
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I
MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO GI. ELEVEN
ZERO. I TO EIGHTEEN AB THIRTY
NINE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO
ZERO. ABSENT MEMBERS. FROM
WE'RE DONE WITH THAT ONE. GREAT
EIGHT ZERO. AND THAT'S IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
TEAM AND TO THE MEMBERS MEETING
ADJOURNED.